Hello, hello, oh shit, wait, why do I have two Twitch alerts
going on?
Okay, let me, okay, there you go, let me fix that real
quick.
All right, hello everybody, hello, welcome to the early
access season 6 preview of Deadpool!
Yes, Deadpool will be coming out later this week on January
16th, very, actually very close it's like in two days um and
for marvel rivals yes we'll finally get deadpool uh for this
uh for next season and i'm thank you again to the marvel
rivals devs for let me try out uh the early giving me early
season access for all of you guys and previewing all the new
stuff that's coming in in season six um we won't i won't be
starting right away it will be in like seven minutes uh
because we have to start exactly at two but i did an early
stream because i want to do some, you know, I don't want to
rush into it.
You know, I go live at two and they were like, all right,
we've got to look through everything right now.
Oh shit, I dropped my controller.
Yeah.
That, I was like, all right guys, gas, gas, gas.
I don't have much time.
I gotta show you everything.
So now I get a little bit of a leeway and I can do a little
bit, you know, chat, chat a little bit before we go straight
into it.
I will say, um, I did try the game a little bit yesterday.
I did talk about it before.
Um, but Deadpool, even though it says zero star, a fucking
lie it has to be the most complicated character i've ever
seen in marvel ravills because it is three different roles
each role he has his own specific abilities and his own
abilities and um uh stats for each role i i will tell you
this right now his info page is It's just all info.
So I was showing to you guys.
So there would be like katana, guns, and then separate
abilities.
And each one has its own giant ass page of dialogue.
Like it's just, I feel like I'm reading a book.
Like it's a lot of text.
We're going to be doing a lot of reading.
I should have like been like, like trying to get used to his
kit.
But then I like try, like I tried.
I like opened up his kid and I like played around a little
bit and I was like I'm done like I was like we're doing it
live tomorrow I'm just like I was just like yesterday I was
just like fuck this I'm doing it live tomorrow like I was
like I'm not reading this without getting paid I'm gonna
read it on stream like reading for free fuck that shit um
anyway uh scarred prime thank you thank you i don't even
think of the tier one so thank you thank you and marvel
rival season 6 will be launching on january 6 um deadpool
will join uh on january 16th and is free to play yes if you
please click on the link pin on the chat or on my panel it
really does help out a lot and also you can play marvel
rivals for free right now yay the game always is always
leveling up non-stop with updates new heroes new team ups
new costumes and yeah don't uh Make sure you don't miss out,
guys.
Good and great.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you, G-Rock.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much.
But anyway, five more minutes, five more minutes before we
can go in, let's watch the trailer for Deadpool.
Also, I did not read the patch notes for all the other
characters because I felt like that one hour that we're
going to have, like always, you guys know the drill.
We've done a lot of these sponsored streams before with
Marvel Rivals.
Huge shout out to them.
um the first hour we test out deadpool by ourselves and then
the next hour we play with the other content creators um i
did tell you guys who the teams were yesterday but if you
guys want a reminder um so you don't be like jump scare
these are the teams that we're going to be in um my team
will be shroud gail cype flats casey and then the enemy team
will be booger xqc moxy j3 guru and kg so those are the two
teams that i know they're there was, like, a lot of people
invited because it is a big, it is a big turn, uh, uh, early
access preview, just because it's Deadpool.
And Deadpool is like one of the, um, the Deadpool is like,
like, you know, one of the Marvel rivals characters, like
not just Marvel rivals, but the Marvel character.
And, you know, he did have like several very successful
movies and stuff.
He is very popular.
So there is a lot of content creators invited.
There is like four different, uh, two different matchups.
So there is team A, B, C, and D.
We won't fighting c or d we're just going to be fighting
team a we're team b um so uh yeah there's a lot of content
creators that have access to there is a lot like i think
like i don't remember i can't count but there is like a
bunch of us um and there are four four uh two matches going
on at the same time um other than that um what else what
else all right yeah let's watch the let's watch the preview
and then maybe by then at two then we can look through
everything together all right let's watch
I actually, I didn't watch, yeah, but like I said, I felt
like we're gonna spend an entire hour on just Deadpool.
So I didn't read the patch notes for the other stuff.
Like, no, you don't understand.
I would not be surprised if the entire hour is just
Deadpool.
I, there's so much stuff going on.
Yeah, and then the upgrades list also has his own fucking
info page too.
And each role has different upgrades.
just like oh my god i'm not reading for free i'm gonna read
on stream
so oh my there's something i need to tell you guys there is
a specific thing um i need to tell you guys about something
yeah you need this he is in from the entire time he's doing
a selfie it's not Just like when he does the when it's the
click it's the entire time he's on camera mode Um, I tested
it out the entire time he's in camera mode.
That's like two seconds of inbound by the way Like you don't
have to time it There's no time and you just click that and
you're invincible like you like I don't he's basically It's
invulnerability Two whole seconds Yeah, so you can shoot his
gun Oh, yeah, by the way, he talks even when you're AFK.
It's literally the mercenary with a mouth.
He literally talks even when you're AFK.
It's very lower accurate.
Gordon.
Barney, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Sarah's, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you all for the support, guys.
He has two ults, too.
He has two ults.
I don't even remember.
Oh yeah, I remember what his first alt is.
I forgot what his second alt is, but he has two alts.
It depends on if you are equipping his katana or his guns.
So you have a gut, like, you know, if you're on your gun,
you have a different alt compared to the katana.
Like I said, it's a lot.
It's a lot.
The first, that's, it says zero stars.
I refuse to believe.
Oh my God, we're in.
Gas, gas, gas.
All right.
We're in.
make sure the volume is on for you guys all right like yeah
nice pat pat for good luck um um we're in all right so i
really want to just go straight and show you deadpool but i
do have to show up people the battle pass and everything i
will tell you guys right now um if you ban deadpool for run
roll you do not ban him for all the other rolls so oh my god
bite size thank you Thank you so much for the 11 gifted
subs.
They can thank you.
That shit is badass, though.
You have to ban him three times.
I can show it to you guys later, but I'll tell you now, you
have to ban Deadpool three fucking times to fully ban
Deadpool.
So you ban Tank Deadpool.
You don't, you don't ban DPS Deadpool or support Deadpool.
That skin is sick.
I will have to say.
I think this skin is pretty.
No, I'm not trolling you.
I wish I was.
I was.
You know what?
I'll show it to you guys.
I'll show you guys this.
It's actually really funny.
I tried it out.
It's pretty funny.
It's really fast.
I'll do it really fast.
All right.
Um, is this tournament mode?
Wait.
Room settings.
Um, Oh shit.
I don't remember how to create a tournament.
Uh, oh wait, here you go.
Create tournament.
I'll show you.
It's pretty funny though.
I swear.
It's very funny.
All right.
I think I did it correctly.
Okay.
It's team Doki Bird versus no one.
The game of the century.
So you see Deadpool.
Oh shit.
And then just don't get why everyone hates on duelists.
has his own line too no at least you can have three
deadpools and one there you go so a bad deadpool and then
and then oh my god who is he gonna protect and then look
okay so deadpool this deadpool is bad he is not zero stars
no look at this look this is the gun And then this is the
katana.
And then this is the upgrades.
And now support Deadpool is bad.
Now I ban duelist Deadpool.
And then I'll protect tank Deadpool.
And oh wait I protected tank.
Yeah.
How many fucking Deadpools are there?
And then it's Deadpool, Deadpool, and Deadpool.
And then, and then we can ban Deadpool again.
And then, all right, they're going, who are they going to,
he never died?
It's so, it's unlimited Deadpool.
It's just all dead.
And then I can ban Deadpool again.
It's Deadpool, Deadpool, Deadpool, Deadpool.
And then I can protect Deadpool.
And...
And then it's just all Deadpool.
Surprise, it's just all...
Surprise, it's just all Deadpool.
Oh, I'm not doing where I can fix it.
Don't worry.
There we go.
So there we go.
Now you understand.
He's everywhere.
you cannot play multiple Deadpool's though you can only play
him you only play one Deadpool but you can ban Deadpool
three fucking times now if only if only I got four
Deadpool's guys then I can also ban him four separate times
Robert thank you for 300 bitties thank you thank you uh next
scene thank you for the 100 bitties they get like how
they're making him more act oh shit drop that girl Dracula
or the wooden knife will finish you off forever what is this
yeah it's not premium oh is it free is he oh no you still
have to get that battle pass um alright there's that oh I
like this one king of clubs this thing skin is sick though
Gordon thank you for the gifted tier 1 sub to whoa thank you
thank you uh kid thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Imagine being a one-trick DPS Deadpool, but your teammate
plays healer.
They give the super chat.
Thank you.
I think this skin is pretty sick.
I like this one.
I just was their...
I think this is their best Moon Knight skin.
I think the whole, like, the whole theming of the clubs
thing is really good in general.
And then there's Bucks.
Oh!
Holy shit!
I love equality, guys.
I I love equality.
Oh my god.
Dude, there's no way.
There's no way he packed that shit.
There's no way.
Guys, equality is great.
All right.
Salute.
Boy wonder.
Oh, I like this one.
I'm going to redeem that.
This one's cute.
That's a cute mantis skin.
There's not a lot of mantis skins that I'm like, Like, oh, I
want, but this one's cute.
Yeah, that's a...
Oh!
What's better than one mantis?
Two mantis.
Yeah, she erpa.
And then there's King of Wakanda.
We have another Black Panther skin here.
Wait, is this...
Oh, that's him!
Oh, that's him proposing!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah, the...
Um, his new MVP is him, like, being like, you want to be my
girl story?
yeah that's it and then he actually oh my god people are
gonna use this you people are gonna use this in time square
a lot we love tachala why but why did they do this is
pre-divorce guys pre-divorce oh queen of wakanda we have
king of wakanda and queen of wakanda we didn't even notice
we have both wakandas yeah Oh my god!
Oh, wait, you can have matching emotes.
Wait, is this the same one?
Or is it, like, different?
Oh, it is.
Yeah, but this one's four-storm, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, this is like, you guys, they can have matching
emotes.
Oh my god, okay, and then there's Disco Invis.
I like her little, the little balls as, like, her private
hair.
I don't know what this hairstyle is called, but that's cute.
Disco's not dead!
I knew it!
it i'm getting that yeah the meatballs the buns yeah i knew
it guys disco's not dead oh my god nothing brings a party to
life like a disco ball oh shit let's go that's cute i like
that one she's literally bring disco back for us She's
single-handedly bringing back disco.
Guys, look at her.
Oh, my God.
We finally get a dance emote, too.
Go, white girl.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
Here's the new Deadpool.
The other alternative Deadpool skin.
I do like the classic skin more.
Because, you know, it's Deadpool.
Oh, and also the 8-bit.
There's going to be like 8-bit skins now, too.
Or, like, retro era.
It's going to, like, mess with people so much.
You're like, is it my graphics, or is he 8-bit?
They're just going to be like, wait, is my RTX, like, dying?
Or is that?
one in the classic spider-man skin right here it is it's
just a little bit it's just a little bit 8-bit oh this is
cool i like it yes i play on low i see no difference yeah
people with the okay this mvp is fucking sick though this
actually looks like it's rendered in the like rendered in
like an 8-bit game i will say this one's really cool for the
mvp all right what's just the spider-man I want the other
characters to have MVPs like this, because I think this is
pretty sick.
It's like a little monkeys, Paul.
They're like, when would we get our classic Spider-Man skin?
And then you're like, guys, see, here it is.
Here's the classic Spider-Man skin, guys.
All right, we gotta grab the...
We gotta equip...
Oh, wait, actually, I want to play with the classic, though.
Oh, yeah, here are the emotes, by the way.
The Deadpool emotes.
He's spanking that ass.
And then here's the Spider-Man.
But yes, you can play Bobo Rivals right now.
It's free, but not season six yet.
Also the new accessories here.
Oh yeah, this is equipped.
Wait, where is it?
Where is it?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, he's biting on the arm.
But let me grab this.
But on the OG skin.
he's biting his ass just so you know i feel like that is um
very important information that i have to let you know um
all right let me where the okay which deadpool i think it's
i'm putting the classic back on yeah so on the classic it's
on his ass it's very critical information and also there's
whack a jeff so we can whack jeff here
Wait, what made Cabin?
Let's see.
Get Chimichangas.
Can I pay to win my Chimichangas?
Wait, I want him.
Give me.
But there's the 8-bit Jeff 2.
Wait, what's the emote?
Someone said his emote is really cute.
Oh, is it this one?
Oh, the chom-chom?
Woo!
I've actually never had Chimichanga.
Alright, Laura.
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
Oh, I showed the battle pass, but um, this goes not dead.
Alright, I think that's all of them.
Alright, it's time.
It's time for the scary part.
Reading time.
It's it's time.
It's time for the, oh wait.
Oh yeah, you guys wanted to see the... Wait, let me...
I forgot to show you guys.
before we do this.
Feels like going back to college.
It's time to start reading, guys.
This is a lie.
This is a fucking lie.
But here are the...
Oh, I like the X-Forest one.
The X-Forest one is cool.
But this is the normal default.
Which is pretty sick.
And then his normal emote.
Yeah, the X-Forest looks really good.
really cool i like that one um and then yeah no like you're
like oh that's not too bad but then there's a second page
and like oh okay that's it right and then there's a third
page
and this one is for duelist by the way you can see that wow
it changes when you swap it changes when you swap stuff
that's just for one role But they are doing a new thing with
the...
So this is the new...
The new upgrade.
There's an animated Lord icon now instead.
So I believe this is...
Yeah, this is the Lord icon for Deadpool.
Because it's animated now.
And you can get other rewards too.
Other than...
Other than the Lord icon.
So you can get like...
I don't know what this is.
But it's a cool ass badge next to you.
And then your Lord icons is now...
uh it's not animated so it's more immersive all right it's
time now it's time for the scary part
okay all right so here you go all right let's start reading
so okay okay all right so the ultimate there's two different
ultimates because see you see here there's the big test and
um a big test and um the katana and let me process this real
quick guys let me just let me process this no i've no it's a
lot it really is a lot um let's see uh anyone all right get
ready to be taunted the band hammer oh my god wait am i let
me check my settings real quick should not be lagging i
don't know if it's deadpool i don't know what it is but i
should theoretically it should not be lagging right now let
me let me double check with my stuff all right it's fine
okay yeah it's his ass i will you know what i would believe
it all right let's turn this down
Alright, so, like I said, there's page 1, and then there's
page 2, and then there's page 3.
So, page 1, this is tank, by the way.
This is tank.
And then there's, get ready to be taunted.
You get bonus HP and healing if you take damage, and I can
get even more.
What the fuck?
oh so if if the enemy team misses you like don't hit you
when you're in all form they take damage yeah i know okay
this is a lot okay
no don't worry you'll understand you'll understand so i'll
show you guys so he has double jump okay so watch this
Wait, is this the right one?
Oh my god, it's the gun.
Give me a sec.
This is the wrong one.
Alright, let me do this again.
Alright, sorry.
I got the wrong one.
Okay, this one.
Watch this part.
Right here.
No, no, there's...
He has two alts.
I got confused about the alt, guys.
He has two alts, guys.
He has two alts.
So, also, here's a bubble.
So, they can't damage through the bubble.
Sorry, I forgot which one is for witch.
It's a lot of pages, okay?
It's a lot of pages.
I got very confused.
All right, get back to my gun.
Anyway, all right, watch this.
This is the, this is the tank.
By the way, I'm on tank right now.
That's why I have 500 HP.
So watch this.
Did I not?
Oh my God, I didn't.
Give me a sec.
Wait, wait, wait.
I got this.
Give me a sec.
I got...
There we go.
See?
They're not hitting me and they take damage.
There we go.
There you go.
There you see?
You see, guys?
You see?
So, if they don't hit me, they take damage.
So you better hit them.
him yes the whole point is that you have to hit him or or it
doesn't work that's it am i still lagging i have no idea why
i'm lagging everything nothing says that everything is fine
on my end so i don't know why i'm lagging right now that's
weird looks like we've got ourselves a party anyway yeah so
she's taunting them so anyway here's my upgrade did you guys
remember what any of I will tell you guys this.
This is very interesting.
So by the way, the poop is the bomb.
It's like a little bomb thing.
It does take a lot to render Deadpool.
That is true.
Yeah, it's all...
Okay, so I'll show you guys this.
I upgrade.
You see those two upgrades I did?
Now, look at this.
I swapped.
I'm like, oh shit, we need another DPS.
So let me swap the dps deadpool i keep my xp just the way so
i keep it and then so i i i can basically like overlap
between which which deadpools i want to play so if i'm like
oh my team needs a my team needs a support deadpool give me
a sec and then i do my upgrades again also it's a lot of
here look oh wait he's dead
He does a lot of heals when he shoots at them.
But his damage is very low.
Like, it's not a lot of damage.
But he does a lot of heals, though.
This heals, too.
Like, my attacks basically are heals.
Not my sword, though.
It's only my gun.
Yeah.
But, his heals does a...
I think his heals does, like, a reasonable amount.
Because I can literally throw my sword.
it out i can throw this out and then heal with it yeah and
then you cannot have all three deadpools in one game
unfortunately um i know it sucks i wish we can but maybe if
i change it to full screen maybe that'll work is that better
oh there we go yeah i'm not lagging anymore yeah we fixed it
i just need it to be full screen there we go that's that's
all much better okay so anyway let's go Take Deadpool.
Let's go back.
It's only when I was in game that was lagging, right?
Oh yeah.
So...
I didn't come here to read.
I know.
Same.
True Deadpool.
I agree.
So let's go through this again.
So his E, if he hits you with Taunt, it basically messes up
your vision and burns your health oh my god so his key
basically you lose your ui i believe when you hit someone
with an e they can't see shit and then f is get xp and
shield my friends when my xp is full i get to upgrade my
abilities score the final hit and force why is the tech so
tidy i'm invincible while striking my best okay for this you
get xp for this i'll show you guys This is the selfie mode.
So, watch this.
Alright, I'm gonna kill him right here.
And then, I take no damage.
So, literally, no damage.
Oh, wait, not this.
That's my upgrade book.
I need to take a picture.
Here, see?
No damage at all.
Two seconds.
Like, you don't have to time it.
It's literally just...
No damage.
You have to kill someone else.
You have to kill someone and then...
Oh my god.
I need to, like, make sure I time.
Okay.
This guy.
And then there you go.
You can't hurt me.
Two whole seconds of no damage.
Yeah, but you have to.
You have to...
You have to kill someone for it, though.
So...
So I can't get hurt from that.
And then there's my bubble.
You can shoot through it.
They can't shoot in it.
I don't know how much the HP is.
It didn't say the HP.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, it doesn't say the HP.
Yeah, you need to get the final hit.
Because it's your kills.
But you can also upgrade.
You get XP for taunting too.
Is this 400 HP?
It doesn't say on this.
So I can't tell how much it is.
it it is a i mean 400 hp is a lot anyway out of combat he
heals so he has passive healing when he's out of combat and
wait what i just processed that wait a minute give me a sec
how long does it take for process how how long does it take
till those passive healing starts up oh my god
And I'm like, oh, wait, excuse me?
That's so fast.
Oh, my God.
I read it, and then I was like, oh, okay.
And then I fully processed it in my head.
I, yeah, that's just like, let me, it's five seconds,
apparently.
And it goes all the way back up to, holy shit.
That is so low accurate.
I would assume his tank is the strongest because it's 400.
It's 500 HP.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
That's the gun, by the way.
What's his katana?
So.
All right.
So his katana.
Okay.
So his katana is just this part.
That's good to know.
Okay.
That's good.
By the way, there's no cooldown for the swap.
Like, there's no cooldown.
I feel like that's pretty broken.
I can be like...
I can literally be like...
I'm gonna shoot you now.
Like that.
Yeah, I feel like that's a little broken, but that's
alright.
Yeah, you can do Gumba...
You can Gumba stomp on them.
So watch this.
But I need to...
Yeah, you can stomp them.
Yeah.
There.
You can chain it.
Yes, you can.
It's like you can do combos, too.
Yeah, so...
Because every time you do a successful...
And then you can stomp him, too.
Yeah, this...
This, the E, the E blinds them.
So, the UI is gone after that.
Why even play Blade anymore?
I think this is very fast.
Like the...
The fucking...
The ship and the slash?
That's so fast.
Like, wait, can I let...
Yeah, I think this is fast.
Who needs...
Oh, wait, you're right!
Who needs reload?
Who needs to reload?
I have no ammo.
I slash.
Yeah, and I have upgraded katanas.
All right, and then we got everything.
All right, let's see.
Let's keep reading.
I don't think I'm done reading yet.
I don't think I'll get katana.
All right, let's see what my upgrades do.
So this is tank upgrade.
Okay, plus my crew gets a damp...
Jesus, Christ.
Christ, the text is so small.
I feel like...
Read for me, Doki.
Okay.
Teammates... Okay, I'm looking at magical unicorn shield
upgraded.
My...
Okay, wait.
With the upgraded katana, my stabs hits crit and a bunny
bounce hit makes you the next swing a stabby special.
So if you manage to stomp on their heads, your next swing is
like a crit.
The The boom is really good.
The boom is because it's an extra, like, explosive thing,
which I showed you guys, so.
It does a lot of damage.
Okay, it does a lot if I get it here.
Okay, if I...
Okay, and then...
Okay, I counted it wrong.
Give me a sec.
All right, there we go.
There we go.
All right.
I think I upgraded everything.
All right, give me a sec.
Let me go back to reading.
All right.
He's going to be very hard to learn, I feel like.
I feel like it's going to be a while till people realize how
to play him because he's so hard to learn.
Because you have to learn all three roles of Deadpool.
Because I feel like the strongest Deadpool player is someone
that can be very versatile on Deadpool and can be like, can
play, what are these?
Bro, there's like, there's three pages.
It's like the tiniest text I ever see.
Like this is, okay, okay, look at Emma.
this is emma's abilities and then we swapped a deadpool and
i feel like i'm reading a novel right now i'm freaking i'm
reading a freaking novel okay um you cute character okay um
so has upgraded i thought bro i'm just gonna upgrade stuff i
don't zero difficulty character by the way all right so his
e he blinds people and your teammates who are in your e
circle gets a damage reduction buff so they're basically
invincible
um and if like the enemy team um the enemy team is in your e
they lose their ui that's insane if i was like if i just
have my ui is gone i'm like I don't know my cooldowns.
I have to, like, internally.
Okay, his...
Okay, his first up, the Banhammer.
I assume the Banhammer is for the gun.
Okay, that is for...
He has bonus health and healing.
And...
And if they miss their abilities, they take ongoing damage.
And the more damage they take, the more HP I get.
heal if they if they missed their shots on me basically and
then the second one the katana the katana basically it is
speed healing dashes and bonus health and then you can
unlock super buffs massive speed and healing and his healing
factor resets so each hit means more hp for the crew and so
your teammates will get oh my god wait this is like a
support as a tank so basically if if i use my uh here and i
can it can make it last for a very long time too apparently
so okay whoops so i oh my god so my all is still going my oh
oh all right so apparently you can get like a really long
all if you get like five combos Yeah, I have all my HP back,
too.
So if I do, like, a combo, I think I would get, like, a
super long.
A super long, like, oh, let me see if I can do it correctly.
800, yeah, I got 800 HP, yeah.
Yeah, he's basically, like, a Captain America, too, if you
think about it.
I just need to...
I need to hit, like...
Okay, four.
No!
Give me longer!
I think I can master.
If you hit five, you get a really long ult.
It lasts forever.
You have to hit up to five, though, for it.
All right, let me try again.
Yeah, I think the Vandga, I think Tank Deadpool might be the
strongest.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
Yeah, see, you can have...
Look, you have longer ult now.
like oh my god i'm so i'm invincible so now i have like uh i
don't know it gave me seven more seconds if i can hit the
combo that's three and baby makes yeah and you get yourself
your speed boost uh what was it speed boost where is it
speed and healing buffs and then extra hp so you have Megas
and then your team your team also gets the heals Anyway, so
that's Vanguard Deadpool Anyway, now that we looked at
Vanguard Deadpool Let's look at TPS Deadpool Anyway, that's
one out of three guys That's one out of three Alright, let's
read Let's read duelist Deadpool now see what's different
about him um so oh my god wait is this all different too
wait give me a sec okay the band hammer okay the band hammer
skill issue okay so it's all it is a little different so um
boom gavel drops and i slapped him with okay so it's pretty
similar um in terms of I assume it's pretty similar.
We're...
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, he takes a lot more damage.
Oh, yeah.
No, that's a lot more damage.
That's a lot.
So if you were like, fuck that guy in particular, I could
just kill him with my ult, I feel.
Like...
Yeah.
Yeah, no.
That guy's dead.
Yeah.
So I assume like, if you hate one particular player, they're
just dead.
skill yeah yeah ult them and then hide behind a wall that is
true yeah wait so the tank one is different the tank one
gets bonus hp and healing with the ult so oh my god wait oh
wait that's crazy wait no the tank deadpool is all vanguard
deadpool is the strongest because not only does he kill
someone with his ult like just one person but he also gets
bonus heals and bonus heals and um yeah and like like extra
heals that's crazy all right so trio taunts mess up their
vision tankster hits okay what's different okay it has to
beat the headshot ever see someone throw their own face
watch me ko a crowd Then catch my mug.
Don't lose your head over it.
I assume...
Oh!
He throws his head.
How do I throw my head?
Oh, wait.
Did I throw my head?
Oh, it's this.
Oh!
It's a boomer...
That's this extra thing.
Wait, it's like a little boomerang.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
That's crazy.
That's so long.
Yeah, oh, he's throwing my character.
Yeah, it's like...
That's so long, too.
If they're all like...
We're all like tank, like, doing like...
Oh yeah, my lord icon.
Yeah, it's like three throws.
If it's upgraded, that is true.
That is the upgraded.
But that's crazy for it upgraded.
That's crazy for it upgraded here.
it's because you it's three hits for a fully upgraded uh
thing yeah i mean page three where is it there you go jogo
doesn't say how much the upgrade is but if you catch it
thrice oh if you catch it you have to catch it too yeah you
have to catch this and then keep talking Plus, I tank hits
like a champ.
Enemies dead.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Speed.
Oh my god.
For the duelist ult.
Wait.
Get katana ult.
Okay.
So if you have your katana and you ult with your katana, you
get speed, healing.
And with the upgrade, you get damage up.
you can unlock super speed, super healing, super damage
boost, and reset all your cooldowns except healing factor
though, but oh Jesus Christ
okay so if you upgrade your katana up super speed, super
healing, and super damage boost I don't think your buddies
get it though at least the good part is that unlike the tank
up Your teammates, your teammates don't get the, don't get
the buffs, I assume, from what I read.
So, so, literally.
Yeah, okay, I killed everyone.
No one's spawning it anymore.
Oh my god, and I got, oh my god.
This is a fucking crazy long haul.
This is a crazy long haul.
i don't know okay i assume all right looking at all the dead
pools the tank and the dps pool seems the scariest to me um
you feel that so fast okay i will say i will say looking at
all of it um his the tank and dps would be the scariest i
assume the support is not as scary because like you don't do
as much damage um but you do do a lot of healing so oh yeah
imagine that with oh my god bro imagine dps pool or tank
pool with damp it all as well that's insane oh my god you'd
be like like you'll be the speed of light it's really the
speed of light when you're doing it all right So luckily the
only thing different with DPS and tank is that their right
their their right click is the the thing the little spinning
thing so that's different so that's good so I don't have to
and their alts it's the right click and the alt that's
different everything else seems to be the same I hope like I
said I told you guys like that's why I didn't read the patch
notes for the other characters because I felt like we're
gonna Spend all our time figuring out Deadpool together.
We have to learn this to get there.
Okay, so we got this guy.
This is a team effort.
All right.
Anyway, now support Deadpool.
This is why I say he does not stop.
Okay, support Deadpool.
All right.
His difference is that...
heal my area touch my team and I dash Lacey down score hit
deal damage and heal my allies in the area okay so oh
oh you can you can jump on your teammates to heal them
basically alright so this heals and then I can jump on you
to heal you and then this this is a healing ring like so
this this is a healing ring now instead instead of a instead
of a buff ring this ring heals you wait wasn't the DPS one a
damage boost for E?
Guys I'm mixing up my fucking deadpools now give me a sec
I'm mixing up my rolls I remember the DPS deadpool the E I
roast messed up their visions and tanked oh no okay so the E
for DPS is just a taunt It doesn't do anything special.
Oh, wait, no, again!
Okay, keep talking, even block your screen, but then they
won't even find...
Okay, so, for DPS, it's just a taunt, so it disables their
UI.
Or not disables their UI, it makes it so their UI is hard to
see.
And burn your health non-stop.
I swear to God that it was different.
Okay, so the tank one is...
Oh, here we go!
And the tank one is damage reduction.
Alright, now I see it.
So tank e is damage reduction the dps e is nothing they
don't get shit you're already dps you get everything you
want um the the support e is uh when you upgrade it
obviously you get damage buffs and heals like oh shit wait
that's crazy okay so support e is a damage buff no i meant
for your teammates i meant these are teammates get anything
so you get damage resistance on dps if you press e but if
you're a support if your tank doom doom i'm sorry support
deadpool you get uh you get damage bus for your teammates
and heals but if you're a tank deadpool you get uh damage
resistance for your teammates as well jesus christ okay
All right, what are the odds?
Okay, it's Todd.
Todd's that take damage over time and get even more pain
when you miss an ability.
My nearby teammates and I.
Okay, so.
His odds here is that his teammates also get heals for this
one, too.
So, well, my teammates are dead.
Unluckily, this is my aura.
My teammates died when I set it off.
But, you know, it's the thought that counts, you know?
It's the thought that counts.
I tried.
I tried to save them.
And then final exam.
Okay, there we go.
Guys, this is the final exam for Deadpool.
You don't have to go to Spotted or Dying Doll.
It's just a force of habit for me.
It's just a force of habit from other games.
Um, do what the game says and hit another enemies with
upgrade our heals and get bonus HP.
Deadpool's got your back.
Okay, wait.
My nearby teammates and I get a healing off.
Oh, okay.
So it's literally just a...
And get bonus HP.
Okay.
So it's literally just...
It's just everyone gets heals when I...
That's literally it.
I still think tank and DPS dooms a Deadpool.
It's hard.
They both start with D.
I There we go I still think the
It's not that I don't know I don't know if the heals are
that fast But we all get healing though Doom Alright We have
to wait though There is a cooldown because I assume He
builds off so fucking fast That they added their own
cooldown to it.
Like, I assume that's why there is its own cooldown for his
ult.
Like, if you see here, I can't build up all after it's done.
I literally have to wait for the cooldown to end.
Yeah.
So, I'm waiting.
I just assumed the ult goes so fast.
It's, like, too fast to build.
Okay, and then
Yeah, there we go.
Now I have a long ass up.
Now we heal forever.
All right, anyway, that's Deadpool.
Did you all retain any information about Deadpool?
Did you guys...
Don't worry.
I assume, like, like, like, things will get easier over
time.
I assume that.
I really, I really assume things will get easier.
Oh, yeah, and the boom does heal, too.
I just gotta wing it.
Yeah, me too.
Same.
We get it.
Yo, who wants to write a study guide for all of us,
honestly?
I...
No, we're...
Me too, guys.
Me too.
This doesn't heal.
Unfortunately, this doesn't heal.
It has to be the gun.
You can do this.
They're dead, but you can...
Your katana doesn't heal, but...
But when you do this, it heals.
You heal your teammates here.
You heal your teammates with your katana slash.
That's why there's a green aura.
Yeah, so that's why, yeah, you heal off.
Like, your teammates can get healed from that.
I don't think you can get healed, but I assume that...
Okay.
Yeah, your teammates can get healed, though, when you do
this.
Let me read this just to be sure I'm not, like, messing with
you guys.
because every hit near yeah every hit heals nearby allies
yep i was right i assume i was like i see green i see green
so i assume that i am healing people that's what green means
it means heal that's what the color is um anime man think
about the twitch prime thank you thank you
No self-healed?
I...
Guys, he already has self-healed.
This.
And also...
Oh yeah, and I can judge him.
There.
I get healed when he can't hit shit, apparently.
And then...
I have like several...
Okay, here you go.
And then...
Wait, there we go.
There I healed.
There we go.
He has, like, several forms of self-healing.
I think he's fine.
I think he's...
And I'm healed.
So I think he'll be okay.
I think he'll...
What's the range on the jump?
Judge?
Like this far.
Wait.
Wait, can I...
I should just do...
Hey.
Like pretty far, honestly.
Wait a minute.
It's actually...
Alright, how far can I do with this, though?
Wait.
It's not...
Uh...
We'll do here.
It's like...
27 meters.
I think it's pretty far.
If like, I'm like...
If like...
I wonder if I could do it.
Wait, actually, give me a sec.
I have a funny idea.
I'm going to test this out.
Okay, he was dead.
okay he was he was very he was already like super dead i was
not aware of that i wanted to see that and i run away yeah i
was trying to figure that out i want to see what the range
is if i just judge him and i just run away oh you can oh
shit wait i could literally do that and i just fucking run
away like he'll never hit me imagine that yeah so i can run
away after i else yeah i'd just be like poop and then you
can't find me and i water the way water yeah and i water the
way technically them shooting their gun and not shooting at
me is missing they hit my as missing your shot I know that's
pretty wild they're like yep but I'm not aiming for you then
I'm like yeah then that's a skill issue that's it that's a
skill issue because they miss their shots technically that's
insane oh yeah what is the what even is the team up with
dead point dead point wait I guess I see this It's pretty.
What's the team up with Deadpool, Deadpool, Deadpool, and
Jeff?
All right, what is it?
I didn't even look at this.
Deadpool, oh my god, wait.
Okay, Deadpool hands Jeff the land shark a plushie that Jeff
can spit it ahead.
We're continuously taught nearby enemies and block missions.
But allies in range enjoys a plush-powered healing ability.
oh yeah he has a sticky bomb i saw that what the fuck okay
basically he gets a healing bonus so jeff does jeff the
shark a plushie jeff can spit it where he's taught nearby
enemies oh it blocks vision while enemies in range enjoy a
plush power all right why be that oh so it'll block his
vision oh i see but then this will heal oh my god it's like
Water wingsprout things.
Wait, that's cute.
That's like a little...
That's like a little lawn thing.
I need to see this, though.
There is a place where you can program an AI.
Control switch.
I have never done this before, but I want to know...
Oh.
Um... What is Deadpool doing?
Nothing.
What is he...
What is he doing?
Can he fight?
Oh, you can't make him fight?
Never mind.
Oh, wait.
Basic combat.
There we go.
Wait.
Advanced combat.
Apply.
All right.
Do your thing.
I want to know.
What does it look like?
He's gonna, they're gonna mess me up.
Okay, do your thing.
Oh my god, my UI.
Oh my god.
Alright.
It's like that Necro's clip.
With like three eyes.
But now it's three deadpulls.
Oh my.
Oh, no!
What?
Oh, my God!
So...
So, I assume that, like...
Oh, my...
I actually can't see shit.
I'm overstimulating right now.
I'm...
Okay.
That was interesting.
That...
Okay,
well, at least there's only one Deadpool instead of three.
At least I'm missing.
Can you do that again?
The problem, I got you.
Okay, let's have one.
Maybe we'll have one.
And see, like, how bad that is.
Four, three, two, one.
come on do your thing come on do your thing he's less
aggressive when there's one of them there you okay okay and
then all right okay so it's like that it's not as bad as
three i assume when i had three deadpulls when i had three
deadpulls it was like they just spammed all three
it is pretty bad but like three deadpools was a lot this was
still this is still a lot but three was definitely over
stimulation there you go and apparently um if you stay in
too long he he locks your ui you don't get a deadpool we're
stopping i'm out oh my god i am out of the area
Deadpool train he's just like I'm not done with you yet I'm
trying to fucking leave the training arena plays play
Daredevil against Deadpool I think Daredevil might win not
gonna lie imagine that in 18 I do not want to imagine that
it looks really like it's a lie it really is a lot anyway
did you guys enjoy the preview the dead i i think the most
fun has to be either tank or a dps deadpool i'm pretty sure
i think the support deadpool is much more balanced i will
assume i feel like the support deadpool is much more that
balance i think i'm gonna be very confused about cheese i
don't need my reload is so fast too if you think about it
like this reload is fast this is a fast reload I am oh like
and I have 40 like I have 40 bullets like I'd never have to
reload again I never have to reload I'm like I have like I
will say I do have like muscle memory from Gambit shift yeah
but for support this is really fast for support i swear to
god every time i play like luna or some shit i feel like i
take like 20 years to reload and she has like more less ammo
too she literally has less ammo i think tank pool is the
strongest only because you can run go from 500 hp to fucking
800 that is that should be legal that that that should not
be legal.
Oh, wait, isn't there a new map, too?
Oh, we never looked at the map.
Sorry, guys.
And I was right.
It takes an entire hour to showcase Deadpool.
I was right.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it would be I knew it would be like, oh, map is not
out yet?
Okay, good.
Okay, I didn't forget anything.
Anyway, guys, again, I want to say before we go meet the
other creators I'll say thank you again to the devs for
inviting me for the Marvel Rivals season 6 early access.
Remember, Deadpool is launching on January 16th and Marvel
Rivals is free to play.
And there's always going to be like, you know, new updates
coming in all the time, especially every half season.
So make sure to click on the link pinned in my chat and on
the panel below to support this stream and also support, you
know, Marvel Rivals.
It really does help me out a lot.
All right, apparently, all right, let me go join the crowd.
I don't know, sound team.
If you're here, I'm going to need you to message me on
Discord for this because this is Twitch and you'll know the
drill.
Okay, I need to make sure I need to restart my Discord
because every time I do stuff on Discord where I have to
interact with people, it has to be admin.
Run as admin.
I have to run as admin so I can mute myself i don't even
remember what button i used for it but but but but i hope i
showcased everything i'm sorry it was a lot it was it was a
lot to showcase it is definitely the most complicated
character that's ever been released yeah i tried to
invincibility um the only new team up is the spider-man um
it's just a lot because you have to remember what each
character does and like his because like each of the buffs
and the buffs he gives is different for each role and like
that's like i guess i'll just have to remember the support
buffs yeah i just have to remember um the support those
support buffs and then that'll be fine but like for anyone
for like the people the super versatile people they'll have
to remember more
I mean, it was literally a fucking novel.
I did the best I could.
I tried to read a novel in one hour.
Alright, I'm in.
I just need to add the Discord overlay real quick, guys.
There's Discord overlay time.
What are you waiting for?
We're waiting for me joining the Marvel Rivals...
I'm in it, but I need to join.
What team B voice?
Is this the right?
Oh, that's not the right.
Team BVC.
There you go.
Let's see if it works.
Sometimes my Fuggy stuff likes to be like, likes to fuck
with me.
So we'll see how it goes.
Yep.
I just think it does.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Here it is.
That's not the right one, though.
I need the one where they're, like, horizontal.
There we go.
Yay, it works.
That's us.
Who the fuck is the Hello Kitty Shadow?
Oh, okay, it's Casey.
It's like, who's Akkan instead?
The Hello Kitty Shadow.
There we go.
I think we just wait.
We're just waiting for, like, the key to go.
Uh, I assume it's...
custom game is it this one where are we joining oh it's okay
they're not waiting for me team b chat okay three roll three
roll deadpool there you go we're lobby two not last let's go
i think our team is here now except for flats but they still
need two but not last let's go mm-hmm common okay one more
now who's the last guy missing wait are we last two uh x not
surprised and he lived again
not last no i'm nervous i know i always say that i was like
dude why are you like one digit mess hi when when did i used
to have a thing like that and now i have a horrible internet
a lot of people oh no just a little worse yeah i don't know
i can't even imagine what it feels like to play on seven ms
i mean i have 21 not too bad but yeah yeah the 21 is like
it's all playable but like for sure like getting like 10
ping and then getting like 60 oh my god it's so now like i
cry yeah no legit legit especially if i'm playing like bucky
i noticed it's so much gil can come down type b too all
right where's this there's so many servers okay gil can come
down wait who do we lose we lost okay what no i'm i'm here
i'm here oh it's kasey yeah yeah i just got here i think i'm
in the wrong lobby i don't think you're in our lobby yeah
you might be in the wrong one yeah so you guys i talked i've
interacted also sound guy i have I have lowered Saip and
Gail.
So let me know if everything is good.
See, guys, character development.
All right, who's playing Deadpool first?
I think everyone wants to play Deadpool first.
Whoever wants it, yeah, can have it.
Whoever has the fastest PC.
All right, it's me.
I want it.
I'm not going to lie, but I'm okay with it.
It's me.
forgot to wait i'm gonna lock it in as tank and then i'll
swap the support because i just want to grab him why didn't
you doing that in tank i assume because he's like i was like
oh i didn't do the that looks crazy wait oh wait no straddle
has the fastest one no you're right that's you're right with
this million dollar pc who's uh who's who's gonna play
deadpool first uh we can do whenever has the fastest pc
plays deadpool first oh geez i like that i like that that
i'm locked in i told you the speed tv show where you have
the same like we're on the same wavelength guys i told you
we have the same we have the same brain a girl can come down
you're saying we're ready yo he's like oh i guess i'm
getting dead fool gotta win oh god okay i have to tap back
in okay fast bc go go go go come on oh shit No, I have to
boot up this map.
It's me.
No.
That was fair, dude.
The Vanguard's first.
It's at the top.
I had to scroll to the DPS bar.
I was going to grab the Vanguard and then swap the support
later.
Oh, that's so smart.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Half a second.
I actually had it.
Okay, like, who got changed this season that I could try
out?
Namor had a rework, right?
A small rework?
Yeah, Namor is more consistent, supposedly.
He is more consistent.
Yeah.
I'm trying Blade.
Blade got changed a lot.
Oh, yeah, I heard Blade is super strong now.
Yeah, I'm excited.
I feel like every time I try this character before, he has
not been good.
So I'm hoping this time.
You're right.
Yeah, the idea of Blade being cool is sick, right?
Like, he should be good.
Right.
Like, get him in there.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh, wait.
I could try rogue.
Yeah, that might be embarrassing.
I've never played rogue.
Are you guys okay with that?
Oh, yeah, go for it.
Rogue is so fun.
Actually so fun.
Especially with Gambit.
That team up is so strong.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got the, yeah.
Let's just play all the team ups.
Four, three, two, one.
I have no clue what she does.
I'll follow you flat.
Oh, goodbye.
No, no, go there.
Nah.
Oh, skill diff.
Right there.
So the better player did not.
fall for the portal bait no he would he would in this fell
for it again oh my god wait there's someone right one bro
they're playing a hella like what are we what are we doing
right now moxie's out here to win they're here to win
they're here to make tick tock videos bro i'm following you
flats let's get in there oh oh don't worry i have a lot of
damage there's a there's they're playing hella anymore oh my
god okay okay they're they're playing they're trying too
hard we need to watch we won guys wait are we gonna sweat
too oh literally running hella name one yeah this is gonna
be bossy okay guys guys i don't want to be on a youtube
video unless it's my youtube video unless it's mine i bugger
is clipped and shipped out already as we speak i also just
can't i can't play rogue i'm sorry You're going to have solo
tank.
I don't know what I'm doing with her.
I really have no clue.
Blatt's got that.
Does we have anyone that could challenge Jella?
Oh, I got that.
That was the wrong way.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Oh, God.
Wait, Heldenmore might be insane.
Goodbye.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
My character might be useless into that.
I'm such cake, guys.
It'll be fine.
Wait, I have the solution.
I will go Widow.
Don't worry, guys.
Oh my god, he was one.
That guy was one.
I think they're top right.
The hell out of my eyes.
Yeah, they are.
Yeah.
They're a little bit bigger now.
You know, I'm having a feeling that Deadpool is not a shield
team.
Just a little.
Oh wait.
Also, there's Neymar behind us.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I got mine.
No way, I have the real solution.
Okay.
The real solution coming up here.
Is it Namur?
The Gale Hulk.
Oh, the Hulk.
The gulch coming out.
Okay.
Wait, you got buffed though.
We got buffed though.
That's right.
Let's see it.
Get me in there.
What did he get buffed with?
His ultimate.
And he also jumps around faster.
I have a feeling that Hello Namur might be behind us.
I got one.
Nice.
Wait, huge.
I'm in there.
I have my little spray here.
Oh.
Oh, purple.
What?
Oh, goodbye, everybody.
Oh, God.
Well.
Yeah.
I do have one, but I will die.
All good.
Oh, my goodness.
We got my ult for next one.
Oh, we got Gambit up.
These both supports.
We do.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're burning, they're burning, they're burning.
They're taking someone off the map.
It's okay, I'm out of the spot.
Care boker, TP.
Kid at me, kid at me, kid at me, kid at me.
He's gonna aim for a shroud.
He wants that clip.
No, he tried.
He tried.
All right, wait, we grouped this corner and we go gambit
all.
Wait, I'm ready, I'm ready.
He's one, he's one.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I'm walking on that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, I can't.
I jumped too high.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
Are you okay?
I'm not good at him.
Okay, okay.
Okay, he died last.
He killed him.
He died.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
They might.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He had TP.
There's no way.
Unless they saw.
Yeah, yeah, he TPed.
He TPed.
Oh, we're good.
Wait, wait.
Invis.
They're stalling.
Let's go.
Nice.
Good stuff, guys.
Look, see?
Oh, we need it.
Someone close.
Over here.
Gotcha, Jeff.
Oh, my goodness.
It's fine.
Dude, Neymar hurts now.
It's going strange.
Yeah, he's strong.
Well, if you have the number one hulk right now.
That's right.
That's true.
That's nasty on hulk.
Yeah, how do you play everything?
It's crazy.
Oh, I can't move.
What is happening?
My character.
Oh, there he comes before you guys.
Wait, guys, guys.
there's a there's a guy on me but actually she's piecing me
up he's on spider that's why he's one okay i'm down i'm down
i'm 70.
yeah i see you moxie moxie's one oh oh shit
i'm out of there no i'm no i'm dead spider-man
oh he is on the spider-man He's trying to pull people off
the map he's trying to pull me looking for it No, sure.
I'll make it.
Oh, nice.
I actually got it.
He's actually got it.
Oh, I'm dead.
He's round two round two.
Not today bogro.
Oh, oh, I'm dead.
Well, I got Invis.
I got I'll fly again.
This will be great.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hey guys.
Hey, Invis is here now.
Oh, Invis is gone.
Oh wait.
You guys okay?
Box C1.
I got one.
Oh wait, we got two.
We got two.
Let's go.
We almost have gamut all.
Bro, that fucking name where shit is strong.
I got two.
Beautiful.
Nice.
I'm in there.
I'm on Bougar with you?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
I'm shielding off his heals with bubble.
Can't be healed.
Wait, Moxie's back.
Wait a minute.
Do you want to keep Morgan?
Yeah, I'm down.
I'm down, I'm coming in.
Look out.
Oh, Moxie's done.
Wait, why didn't he let me...
Oh, I'm out of there.
Spider-Man behind us again.
Nice.
We gotta wait for that.
We can match you match.
We got this.
oh oh it's okay it's okay everything is fine we can get it
all oh nice no i'm in backline i got i'm hoping you i'm on
i'm on strange right now he's that is that strange strange
spider-man spider-man i don't know if that will protect you
from that beat him up beat him up oh wait spider-man though
Wait, it's Spider-Man, guys!
Let's go!
Oh, I keep forgetting my team up.
I'll throw it now.
I keep forgetting I have this.
One behind?
Oh my god!
Destroyed.
He's mentioning you on Hulk now.
He thinks he can dip you.
Nah, nah.
He's You can try.
You've seen your methods.
He played with you for so much.
What are you through?
Spider-Man as well.
I'm pretty sure.
They should see us on these one trick.
Did you?
All right.
Oh, you treat you.
Oh, shit.
XPC is on the wall.
He's on the big wall.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
I'm okay.
No.
Not you, though.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna get killed with this.
Watch this.
I'm getting big wall.
Big wall down.
Oh, goodbye.
I have my ults here, but I don't know if I can.
I'm chilling.
They sold the ults in me.
I lived.
Nice.
I'm back in there.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, oh, I died before a good one.
Wait, gridlock, gridlock.
I'm shooting.
We almost have gambit all if you guys can hold.
On their Deadpool?
I have to reload.
Wait, I'm spinning my...
Oh, that's a lucky.
Oh.
No!
I mean...
Oh my god, who...
You're fine, you're so healthy!
You're strong!
Oh my god, Tron's in the game.
He can win.
Okay, I'm punching him.
have three people out in the back there's nice oh my god
they're flying everywhere get the deadpool i want him he's
one i got him i bubbled he's taking a picture of him he has
two supports take a picture i got his bubble out i'm wearing
a bubble training hold on do i need a second but when you
take the selfie do you are you still on the card technically
i killed them more uh that's a good question actually i
don't know yeah are you like
I've bubbled it.
Oh, nice.
I threw the plushie.
I can't see anything.
They can't see anything.
What's happening?
You're good.
You got it.
Wait, I've ult.
Oh, no.
Okay, I missed the violence.
I'm ulting.
Oh, I think I'm dead though.
That's fine.
We have injuries.
There's a lot of colors on my screen.
There's a lot of colors.
There's so many colors on my screen.
I stunned him.
He can't play the game.
Bougar can't play the game.
We almost have Gambit on, guys.
He's getting pissed off.
I think he's a bubble.
I couldn't tell him.
Super support.
He'll Bougar.
Yay.
Bougar's won.
I'm slashing him.
Oh my god.
He won't go down.
I stunned him again.
I'm eating.
It's okay.
You're all okay.
I'm dead.
You're all healthy.
Come on.
Yes.
No, too easy.
Too easy.
Thank God there's a melee form.
Guys, I think triple support might still be a favorite.
Yeah.
Dude, why was it so colorful at the end there?
Oh, because Deadpool all did.
That's what Deadpool all looks like?
That's the skins too.
The skins changed the all.
Deadpool ult and double invis ult with the music.
Double invis, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, so it's all the colors.
It's like a purple one now.
Yeah.
And then if you're in too long in Deadpool, it hides your
UI.
Oh my God.
Yeah, so that you can't see your cooldowns.
All right, I'm just gonna adjust this sound.
Excuse me, what role would I mid-air collided them in my
ult?
Nice.
I actually can't tell if we'll watch around this.
I don't think I do.
I hope guys is the sound okay now.
Someone said a Deadpool watch like a triple support and
visual clutter.
Yeah.
Look, look, did Walker on normally flat?
He actually does look like a toy figurine.
No.
We don't get it.
It's okay.
We still have two supports.
That's crazy.
It's okay.
We still have two supports.
They're portaling, they're portaling, they're portaling,
they're portaling.
Wait, they're actually trying to pour all you, Casey.
No, no, they're a power out.
Oh, they're sweating.
Oh, they want the win.
They got X on the strain.
Foxy and the Hawkeye.
Oh, he wants the win-win!
I can't see what they're...
Oh, no.
It's okay, you're so healthy.
I can live this.
I'm good, I'm good.
I'm just baby Bruce.
I'm throwing this onto them and see if it sprays them.
I don't think all of them got back.
I don't think that either.
Oh.
Oh, we gotta save our dead pool, guys.
All right.
I got my form.
I got my boat.
We're good.
All right.
Nice, nice.
Stunned the Bucky.
Wait, they're on Mantis.
They don't have a lot of heals.
One sec, one sec.
Oh, I got rolled.
I can't see you.
It's okay.
Oh, goodbye.
What's happening on my screen?
now goodbye i'm sorry i can almost hold you in yeah yeah
stupid shark stupid shark kill j3 deadpool deadpool
deadpools have almost back almost back oh god i'm chilling
oh no not the hawka oh no not the hawka oh i have to reload
i'm sorry oh my god i exploded so much damage
Oh, he turned around just a few.
I respect it.
You're coming back.
I'm swimming.
I'm trying.
Yeah, they want you.
Oh, God, we gotta run.
I don't know.
Oh, Moxie's on the hot guy.
That's why he really, really wants a win he doesn't care
about what the buffs are he's not here to preview he's here
to win all right they're all in i think he's a pop okay i
don't really know how to use jeff so give me a sec i'm like
behind the corner i'm good i have two i have two very nice
oh i'm sorry guys guys i'm gonna send three people in our
back line i'm sending the tps in our back Guys, I actually
gave Hawkeye high ground.
What?
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
I actually gave our Hawkeye high.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't get up there.
That is my bad.
Isn't there a bucky in the back land?
Did we kill the bucky?
Did he die?
I think he died.
Okay, I hope we did kill him.
I was like 7-0.
Let's see, we staggered the Hawkeye.
It's really fun.
Did I kill him?
40 bullets this is crazy i know it's actually i know
literally never reloads really fast too hang on i'm gonna
challenge hang on i'm gonna do this oh oh wait wait wait
wait okay we can not get assaulted nice nice no cruz on wall
that's crazy in the back in back line back line
wait i'm here on him he's one i'm dead oh i'm so Oh my god.
It's me and me here.
That was huge.
Support's coming back.
He's on the ground.
I got you guys.
Oh, I got you.
Oh my god.
Guys, can we still touch boys?
I'm slept.
Come on.
Nice.
Good job.
Ciao.
Ciao, everyone.
Yeah, see, we won the first.
They're portal-like.
Jay's on the Iron Man.
Are they?
Oh, yeah.
They all waited and spawn, yeah.
Where are they?
Oh, high ground.
They're ultimate high ground.
Stop right, stop right, stop right.
Whoa.
I'm doing something stupid.
Let's see it.
Wait, I see it.
I see the vision.
No.
That was a bad idea.
You know, the vision was there.
The vision was there.
The war room chasing me.
I'm stuck.
What the hell?
He has all, he's all, he's all.
Wolverine is all pair.
Alright, round two.
One on the- Oh shit, it's okay, it's okay!
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay,
everything is fine.
Get him.
Aw, they're the bad tusks!
It's okay, see?
The vision was there.
I'm on KG.
Nice.
Oh,
wait.
He's a strategist.
He has like the icon.
Oh, wait.
Is he on the strategist?
Oh, he is.
He's on the strategist.
Yeah.
The strategist is Deadpool.
I think DPS tank Deadpool is the strongest, though.
Yeah, tank heals really good.
Because you could get up to 800 HP.
Come on, Angela.
They're kidnapping him.
Oh, you're fine.
We'll come back.
Oh, my...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
No, I got so old.
It's okay.
He tried to get me to, but I swam away.
He's one on the...
He's one HP.
I just can't hit a shot.
Oh, my God.
I'm swimming away.
I got you, Shroud.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
But he's coming for me.
My hero.
I got Maxi.
Oh, my God.
Look him up.
Wait, there's a...
that was evil all right nice you're doing it guys four axis
game wait can they touch he's playing tank you know what
he's signing for oh wait they're touching they're touching
they're touching never miss what the fuck help thank you you
got you got me in the corner how many people i got two i got
two i'm sending in the back line so it might be a throw i
won't be it i'm punching i'm punching you on point oh my god
i have all the tanks on me Your tanks are on the back.
In the back line, in your back line.
I got him out of here.
No.
I won't go down like this.
I'm dead.
Oh, fuck.
No.
Okay, maybe I should not have sent their tanks to the back
line.
That might have been an oopsie.
We'll have Gambitle.
We should get a DPS Deadpool out there.
Dots?
Oh, DPS Deadpool.
Someone should do it.
Who would that someone be?
Who would that be?
Maybe it could be anyone.
Yeah.
All right, I'll get a shot.
I'll get a shot.
There you go.
Try it out.
Do some damage.
Oh, solo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We could all go in with Gambit all here.
Are we down?
A group of men?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, no, we're last in this.
Fuck.
Oh, no.
rid of it are we good uh we should go here we go yeah oh
what the oh no we couldn't oh i'm so dead out here we have
time we have time full reset yeah i'm going back i'm
returning oh they're portaling wait he's portaling oh
where's the tp i don't know where is he it could be on in
the spies yeah it's here it's here keep it the doors okay he
fucked it up you can go for it yeah
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
No.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's okay.
I'm just insta down.
It's okay.
We just wanted a longer, longer lobby, you know?
Three.
To showcase everything more.
Let's do it.
A longer test run.
True.
Gotta make it interesting.
Okay, I'm gonna kill someone with penny mines.
And then I'll go back to part.
Yeah, do it, do it, do it.
The XQC might be the one dying.
That guy's gonna walk through the garage for sure.
You can make a clip.
The prophecy has been foretold.
Round three.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
We're getting a kill.
He hits us.
It's coming, it's coming.
Yeah, I'm waiting.
Is that a new one going through the garage?
That's unbelievable.
they're already wearing wait guys don't get portals don't
get yeah actually yep there it is oh you're trying you're
trying we've learned they're like on the side here oh yeah
now they are set up
hawkeye top right drop down oh the mirror hook hawkeye's
half hawkeye's low
oh the hawk guy almost killed me
i got all i have to reload oh god that's okay yeah yeah yeah
i'm with you with you on that nice oh on the backline oh my
god yo
i'm okay their backline just fell over you win those you
yeah i got that
Huge!
Big, big, big, big!
Oh!
Yeah, I saw that!
Nice.
I'm 60 to Lala.
Yeah, I'm so mine.
Cool.
We can do Sharknado when I get mine.
Mm-hmm.
I'm gonna hold it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
If I don't get it in time, you can use it.
I'm Groot.
Oh!
Oh, they might go fast.
Yeah, you might have to use it.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going to hold it for a sec.
I'm asleep.
I'm going to try to block his screen.
No.
It's not working.
Wait, wait, no, it's not working.
No.
We have embezzled.
Oh, God.
No.
No, it was a good push though.
It was a good push.
That was a good push.
That was good.
That was unfortunate.
The moxie headshot.
That's crazy.
That's it.
That can be win.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
We got a fast push, so it's winnable.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, don't go through garage.
This guy's going to do a penny lineup.
I think OT, by the way, your thing carries over, but you
don't have like maxed out.
I don't know if it's from like the defensive round or what.
That's interesting.
Wait, so like when we started on defense, you had like
different things?
You started over?
Yeah, I had so like we started off there.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, OK, well, now I can buy everything.
That's weird.
OK, weird.
When we went on attack, I had most of my stuff, but not
everything.
And then I had to buy like two or three things.
Wait, but they're here.
They're here.
I could buy everything.
Yeah, yeah.
I cleared and bow.
Oh, they're back.
It's okay.
Sean would have been the victim there, buddy.
I would have definitely.
I'm moving along, guys.
Don't worry.
I was just reading chat, not paying attention.
Thank you.
I'm moving the line.
Don't worry.
I know their schemes.
No more, no more mines.
No.
Oh.
Three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the lane.
Are they poor lane, Sean?
Oh, no, no, no.
Yes.
Oh, no, they are.
Oh, they are.
They are there.
Wait, care, top side care.
Yep.
Might be TP.
Oh, they're here.
They're here.
Okay.
They'll be flat, so I'll try.
Uh-oh.
Don't get headshot.
Oh, no!
No, Moxie's too good.
He got headshot!
Trying to blind him.
He's just too good.
No.
Oh, God.
I think we all died, though.
so we should get that one right here yeah yeah yeah yeah
wait it's bugged oh wait what wait i don't know my stuff oh
no oh this is can maybe build invisible here i'll try to
take damage taking damage taking damage taking damage oh oh
maybe took a little too much damage 30 people no i couldn't
0.00 no nice fight no the mossy hot guy let me play a first
game that was so fun yeah that was great bring in band
system again
that's unlucky they got headshot you can't count her
headshot That's a lucky first sight thing.
Did it feel fun the DPS is that cool?
At least?
Oh yeah, how was that?
Uh, well, I missed every shot and then died.
So I couldn't, honestly couldn't tell you.
Okay.
It's, you know, you got the effort.
It's the effort.
Yeah.
Okay, I had one good Jeff up.
I had one good Jeff up.
the other two killed my team but other than that i had one
good job
i didn't die with alt though okay i didn't get i didn't die
by a headshot from from moxie though you guys want to try to
you want to try to share deadpool here like i play him for
like i don't know one alt or something and the swap with
somebody yeah maybe sure yeah i can play maf i feel like
we're not gonna have no time to get everybody to like yeah
that's true so yeah okay that went so long i played for one
headshot maybe one maybe one point up and then next point
and it died with up because i got headshot yeah i can stop
with you headshot yeah you should definitely check between
rounds up um like your your thing carries over I'm curious.
Yeah.
I'm curious too.
So in the...
Look, see, Saipi, who is a rank 1 to 6 player, couldn't even
survive.
So checkmate.
I lived longer.
No, I just didn't have the Lady Loki skin on.
Because he got headshot twice.
And that means it happens to everybody.
dude it's been a minute yeah no he feels very good like you
can't be booped anymore in his old it's so nice oh no the tp
on us what the hell they're doing the strats let me win this
oh oh nice you actually see camera nerds look at that they
us and we spin we're just better nice you guys are you guys
okay over there the hulk's out of form he's on Wolverine oh
bottom right here that can't be right i don't know coming
over in the choke point i kind of missed this map wait
Groot's what He's dead.
That is.
One on the Bruce.
Oh, nice.
I'm just chilling in the corner.
I was about here.
Oh, you stunned me.
Oh, I'm in there.
Oh, it's crazy.
I just in, Vaughn.
Shitties is bouncing.
I have to reload.
Oh, nice.
Keep it going, keep it going.
Oh, I'm...
Oh!
Hold on, boy.
Oh, I'm so dead.
Wait, I can keep going.
I'm gonna crazy cleave.
No!
Come on, I'm alive.
Oh, no!
He does!
I got one bolted.
Yeah.
He hit me when I was mid-alting.
You got that flat?
I don't know.
I don't know if I got this one.
I forgot to do the...
I'm getting staggered.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's not okay.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That was insane.
Ah, Boger's evil for that one.
We gotta get payback.
Yeah, we don't have it.
They're trying to wolf.
He missed grab.
I have all.
He's gonna go.
You ready?
Don't worry about it.
Yeah.
I'm in there.
Wait, where is that?
Oh
Yeah, Hulk isn't back alive.
I might need help there Oh Shit we got reset How am I still
alive?
Okay Oh, you guys both went Oh, no No Huge escape
I can get us in there with my old.
Yeah, we're ready.
And I can do it after.
We need to meet Mr. Fantastic.
Oh, you're coming over there.
Three, two, one.
I'm going.
He chose me with it.
One HP on J3.
On J, dead.
Nice.
Wait, where's...
Kill Guru.
He should have.
He can move.
I'm not going to let you in just in case.
Where are you?
Oh my god.
Take it easy.
I'm trying to decide.
I tried my best to go up.
You got ported?
Get him flat.
Get him.
I'm on it.
Oh.
Yeah, I had it.
I'm so dead.
What the fuck?
Okay, I got you.
I'm gonna settle down.
to keep you up it's okay give me a pop next round on point
no no way
i'll give the dps deadpool a spin
no sea land
all right oh yeah i can use his upgrades wait you can use
his upgrades yeah Oh, wait, that's crazy.
Yeah, whoever builds it, it, like, stays, I guess.
It's pretty cool.
This is actually really cool.
Yes, I don't know.
By the way, I'll just click a jet.
Die, by the way.
See if you still have it.
Because I had a bug on our overtime where it would go away.
That's cool that it transfers.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
oh my gosh i forgot this map existed yeah it's been so long
what even is broken about this map uh there's a wolverine
coming in good luck uh oh no they're right here they're
right here oh he's throwing him oh he's going straight for
you oh hell no he's one there is a hook on me
Oh, wait, wait, wait, it's okay.
He got himself too.
I have it.
Hulk on me.
I might need help.
Here's one.
He's still on me.
Yeah, he's Hulk is on you now.
Oh, I'm dead here.
Oh, it didn't go off.
Oh, my God.
Bring grew walls.
Trying to at least.
I'm going crazy in the back Oh shit, nice We're coming back
Oh my god We're coming over What was this?
Almost got you Oh, help Oh, one, hook one Wait, where are
you?
Yeah, where'd you go?
He's one, he's one Yeah, he's low, he's low Oh, no That's
okay, we stunned him though I tried He's one, he's one Nice
You should have staggered him staggered me i think i dashed
30 times in that one time i should take that yeah that
character is wild nah wow that was personal i break it nah
okay good luck i mean okay sure now he is a creep for that
one he's creepy i'm gonna use this in advance you got it
Clear the way.
Damage never falls!
Disappear!
Nice man.
Here we'll rewind.
Yeah, Wolverine's on.
Oh, Wobby's low!
Looking for me.
Yeah, he's low.
What is going on?
On my screen!
What is going on on my screen?
Nice.
There's a hug behind us.
Oh!
He's asking for the help back.
Oh, Deadpool support.
He's on a spline.
I have many faces.
I can hear him behind.
I can hear the hook behind us.
Yeah, he's one of you wanting me in this room.
Hey, there's that Wolverine here.
Oh, goodbye.
What the fuck?
I glitched through the wall.
I saw that.
What the?
I mean, thank you.
he like saved you yeah okay now i know why this rank this
map isn't in rotation
hey i'm on it i'm on it wait i cannot kill my shoulder okay
he missed his robot yeah he oh one mags one nice
yeah i think my shield is bugged i honor rank that cannot
pull it back it keeps like respawning on the same point on
like maybe maybe it's a map thing like i put my i put my
shield in the middle of the map and every time i put it back
it just like reappears after one second like what i didn't
even have a shell fresh you didn't need it the images are
actually good though you would like that glad what did
change like the image and you like charge your beam faster
now oh yeah oh oh he's like way faster like coming online
that's gonna feel good yeah yeah yeah because i feel like
before he was struggling a bit to keep up in like the meta
but i think now she's pretty good the
battle starts in five four three two two one all you need to
do is capture the mission area got it sounds easy which
means it's probably not right you're about to find out oh
there's a there's a teleporting oh he's flying back he's
dead oh he's trying to get real nice he flew to us holy that
was crazy it was a flying oh i'm dead oh goodbye oh i can
see you i got i got grabbed from like i didn't mean to be on
that side and grabbed me i think he has i think Okay.
Oh my gosh.
You got past one.
And I can do this.
I can't see anything.
Yeah.
I'm in.
Oh my god.
Hope one be one.
Wait, wait.
He's slow.
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
See?
Fun?
I know.
That's personal.
Oh my god.
Does that mean I can start redecorating it now?
Oh.
Someone's all right.
Yeah.
Who's that?
I'm pretty sure they have.
Oh, yeah.
Gambit.
He's low.
You're so healthy.
Oh, yeah.
It's really fast.
We have this.
Never mind.
We died.
Oh, I saw that.
Oh, God.
Never mind.
The lambs, bro.
We had three lambs, but it didn't matter.
Where is the grid ult?
Oh, he's coming for you.
He's coming for you, Shroud.
You're all coming.
Oh, goodbye.
J.
I'm everywhere.
Are they throwing Wolverine?
Where is he?
He's right side.
Right side.
Oh my, I don't know if you get this.
Okay.
There's a lot of stuff going on our screens right now.
I don't have Involve.
I don't have...
All right, well, I'll kill one.
I'm dead though.
One out of five.
I do have ult soon.
Let me stop.
I don't know.
Their team's capture progress has passed a halfway point.
Right side starlord.
We're long in time.
I got him.
Okay.
I should live through this.
I pulled back Wolf.
Wolf in your back, Wolf.
Yeah, Wolf's in the back of the eye.
What the?
I'm stuck in the wolf.
Yeah, I was gonna stay weird.
I don't have it yet.
Hang on.
No!
Jesus, Hawk is low.
Oh my god, he grabbed me off.
Oh no.
Is that him all?
We'll bind, we'll bind, we'll bind.
We get one, we get one.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
Very winnable.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm on Gambit now, so it could be winnable.
Oh, we got this then.
Um...
I can't get him.
Come on, I can't get him.
No time for a pay-do-do.
We still got work to do.
Then
half of the mission area, keep going.
Bring a wall.
Yeah.
We don't have anything for that.
I'm dead.
They're all on me.
Oh, yeah.
They all ran at me.
Oh, my.
Jesus.
Yeah, it's just the gambit.
Let me try a die point or something.
Oh, I'm going to need to TP.
Yeah.
Oh, I don't know if you'll live, but we're trying.
Oh yeah, you'll live!
You'll live, you'll live, you'll live, you'll live!
Are you going crazy?
Drudge!
Oh my God!
I tried so hard to keep you alive.
Okay, yeah, that was crazy.
Good and, well, maybe.
I can't help you.
Oh my God, I'm mean, no!
Yeah, they're on our supports.
We...
Wait, Flats got that!
You got pushed.
I got pushed up!
The push!
Ah...
They just try.
Ah.
Their just try.
it was close that was close though no we just yeah the
support back line just was like there was nothing you do
with gambit all it's like unless you have a counter support
like you're you're not gonna live it was unfortunate why not
that image and he did so well not obviously That's good,
Paul Gale.
It was good.
No, I think he's really strong.
I was just, uh, brute and will vaulted basically every
fight.
Yeah.
That didn't really help my case.
Yeah, all good though.
Yeah, no, he's, uh, he's really in my opinion.
Really good.
He doesn't have much follow-up right on his guns.
So you can do pretty good damage even on Grinch.
Yeah.
It's like, it's kind of like Hella, no?
Like Hella Phoenix a little bit The projectiles are actually
as well.
And like, I honestly think you ult on his guns and then swap
to his blades after.
Because like...
The gun is the one where they miss, they take damage, right?
Yeah, yeah.
All right, support gamutad.
I think that's the plan.
Well, who do you put it on?
What's that?
When you were targeting one person, who did you put it on?
Oh, I would just look at their DPS.
Oh, okay.
Well, I'd be a nice person who gives sight bait.
gambit one time i'm not gonna start i put it on gambit or do
i take yeah like gambit misses a lot of abilities right sure
all right let's see who's fastest my strategy die first and
gg no heal go oh well you're gonna try to heal okay
i'll do one round and then either cypher case he can do the
next one
i think it's better to be the second deadpool so you can get
all my all the skills all the xp true yeah royal blade is
this a new team up or is this one in the game with magnito
oh with gambit oh yeah
there we go
to find out oh i hear them to the right oh then we're moving
again oh god there's a thing i think where are they oh there
they are it's on thing i think emma is crazy do you be
behind oh nice slice him up he's one i've always wanted my
own got the rocket beacon oh my god whoa I should have
bubbled you.
I don't have how far on.
I don't blame Magneto.
No, it's fine.
My character literally dies so fast.
Wait, I have ult already?
What the fuck?
BP.
Wait, the ult is so fast.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
wait Deadpool also builds so fast yeah yeah it's because you
need to like have combo points to have it it's not like
normal charge oh I see it's like the more damage and healing
you do the faster you come here to read yeah I think like
hitting things with your abilities too yeah no wonder he has
like a cooldown for it oh wait they're in the back in the
back what Marcia's got two tapped though yeah
Okay, I fucking dashed into that.
I got two, I got two.
Nice, thank you.
See that?
Oh, I'm dead here.
Oh.
Come over here.
Nice.
I think this gun is really good now.
Nice use this.
There's a beep gun right.
now understand what shaw said he was just pressing buttons
yeah yeah a lot's going on yeah i have oh i guess i'll use
my katana for it oh oh oh good nice i mean i could i don't
know if i should okay i'll ult him when they're closer I got
him.
We could go faster with Gambit all.
Can we go?
I'm going.
I can Gambit all here.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I didn't get it.
Oh my god, I got fucking loaded.
I used my Katano too.
Oh, good.
We got an X-Fi.
Oh, and E.
Yeah.
come on i didn't come here to read there's a bp hanging
somewhere with yeah oh i think you're right about that the
thing is gonna run at us but he's old in a second yeah yeah
they're looking to go oh god oh goodbye everybody oh my god
you were right oh my god oh it's okay save the back gap the
back gap we got the back gap i'm out i'm running you might
need to tp Oh, wait, yeah, Loki.
Well, it's okay.
I guess we are TPing.
I got one more touch in me.
We're TPing.
I cannot do this all day.
The flat's carrying.
We're going in.
Let's go.
Nice, nice.
Huge.
If I make it back, I got casted.
oh my god i got instant destroyed there my character sucks
we're gonna do more they're porting to was blade not working
out or what nah yeah does not feel very good oh my god i hit
that zero way big oh my god oh i tried They win a ball.
Oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Can I see?
There's one.
Oh, my God.
The reload.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's close.
Oh, it just goes too.
So close.
Okay.
We got next round.
He's definitely very overwhelming.
Swapping between the two.
A lot of buttons.
Yeah, definitely a lot.
Wait, am I going Deadpool?
Yeah, you can go Deadpool.
If we win this, we gotta win this so we can have a third
person on Deadpool.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I can...
Yeah, you have every... You should have like half of
everything.
Is there a way to know how many things you can buy?
Does it say?
It just stops.
Oh, it just stops, okay.
Yeah.
I won't let it take
any...
The battle starts in five.
four three two one all you need to do is capture the mission
area got it hey thanks thanks all right here we go oh
there's spider-man yes spider-man they're going all high
ground yep oh thank god yeah you got to see
Oh, VP dead.
I have Invon, but I might be dead.
Oh, I'm dead.
Yeah, no.
Oh, all supports dead.
I always come back.
Here's all Gambit all when I come back.
Good hold.
We're coming back.
Am I all?
Are we in a Gambit all?
and they're devolt in their backland they walk up i'll call
it i'll call it i have a lesson too we're all gonna w key
it's okay you're a deadpool you can kill him all right yeah
he's running he's afraid though all right he's all dead
that's good i'm ready i'm ready yeah let's get it all let's
go
i can't see anything what is happening what is happening Oh,
I'm dead.
I have to reload.
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
The damage?
Everything?
What the fuck?
It's like everything.
Like, what happened?
We went down one support.
We just got to kill their cloak.
I don't know what's happening.
Oh, they just ulted too.
No.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
I'm invisible.
That's a clip.
Is there still a Spenamin in those fun?
Yeah.
in i can i can help this too yeah all right we're gonna
liberate the backline he's upside well yeah all right that's
ready damn oh i want to walk off there we go what the fuck
okay buddy wait spy man's Wait, Black Panther is one too.
He's one.
Nice.
Good stuff, good stuff.
Let's go.
Oh, they have support Deadpool now.
I don't even know how to use the Deadpool to support.
Oh, yeah.
I think it's like an area around here.
I'm out.
Oh, I can reflect his.
Oh, excellent.
You don't have anything.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm dead.
No, he's being off to me.
Oh, never mind.
I thought I was keeping Flats alive.
You got me alive.
I'm running.
We gambit the devil.
We got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
All right, I'm going forward.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, I'll let.
Whoa, what the fuck is that?
That?
Oh, he missed, he missed, he missed.
It's an over special.
One, one, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Hey, yeah, yeah.
Hey, ready, ready?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I had to use Involve, but yeah, we're ready.
And I'm getting a little thing.
Sorry, Pin, I didn't get it.
It's okay.
Maybe you can keep me up.
I'll keep you up.
never mind we can't keep it's okay i believe in cypher oh
nice nope i did i'm yeah yeah cypher i didn't get the gambit
okay okay yeah there's a venom touching too you're welcome
oh jesus i can't hold i can i have all for this but i need
to be able to see your gambit okay i'll come back i'll come
back you'll have to keep fighting
There's a lot of things going on back here.
None of them are good for me.
Oh god.
Melt him, melt him, melt him, he could die.
Oh, he's one.
Nice.
Oh no.
I literally can't see anything.
I can't see anything.
I assume shit as well.
No, we lost his support.
Wait, uh...
If you guys can live, we have TP.
Oh, we have supports are dead.
Wait, sure, wait, sure, you're too.
Child supporting, he's supporting.
Nice?
Yes!
Let's go!
Come on, man.
Now we can have the third support, Deadpool.
Huge.
his bullets are so small yeah yeah i agree they are yeah
yeah i'd be very precise but like i don't think headshots
give more heals though okay so what is this character what
does rogue do can i get a rundown uh so your f like takes
other people's abilities um you only get like one of them so
like for strange for example you'll like take a shield uh
for like mantis to take her sleep and so on her E, you like
dash into them, kick them up in the air and then boop them
down on the ground and then for the next two attacks you
have like a ranged like kick attack that does damage.
And then your shift is you dash forward and then you click
shift again and it creates a circle around you that pulls
enemies towards you.
And also the block, if you block and then hit left click,
you like do a shoulder bash.
Holy crap.
Oh, this is the Spider-Man.
And then your old steel alt charge if they're over 80
percent oh this was the spider-man map huge yeah that's good
oh i might have just got absolutely full boxed yes they're
he's portaling is that opening a portal i guess wait that
was fire okay i forgot that this was my bad almost back
almost back
so I copied her.
Oh, I'm dead.
What was the day he is?
They used it.
I think they have everything.
Yeah, I don't think they used anything.
Oh, I saved you, but you can't get saved a second time.
Wait, they did wall.
Again.
um he's gonna use my odds yep oh oh oh please can you punish
him holy oh wait air from back swing those cds i'm gonna do
i got him oh before huge i can go oh oh my goodness oh nice
We're going to disappear.
Huge cleanse.
What is gold?
Go through maybe?
Oh my god.
What is that?
I can't see anything.
What is happening?
Yeah, that was insane.
Everything is happening.
Yo, that looked crazy.
That was roguel dare to fall.
You can't really see anything.
Yeah, I backed away.
That was a little bit too much.
Spider-Man right side gun for full.
He missed.
Oh, no.
We got different ones.
I want them.
I'm dead.
Bye, everyone.
I'm swimming away.
No, I couldn't.
Oh.
All right.
I can TP.
Can we though they're all like there?
He ping?
Oh god, he's gonna stun me.
That's okay.
I'm giving you heals.
Oh god.
No!
It's not okay!
It's not okay.
I almost had it.
Oh yeah, you could turn the visual effects off on the
settings.
I'm definitely gonna turn that off.
For like scenes and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
When there's everyone skins on there.
That's what...
so many particles as well.
Like, whenever he's, like, the sword is out, you're at the
right click that you, like, throw.
Like, there's so many things happening.
Yeah, yeah, that's why I was like, I'm just going to press
buttons.
I...
Yeah, that's crazy.
I feel like Season 7 needs to take a step into clarity,
maybe.
Visual clarity.
I don't know.
It's getting kind of fucking crazy.
The clutter was insane.
No, for sure.
It was nuts.
I think...
Is that it?
Yeah, I think so.
He stopped it.
I think so.
You get a chance to do the all Deadpool though.
But I think it's just the games were really long.
Yeah.
That was fun.
At least we were about to play Deadpool 1.
At least one thing.
I think so.
Yeah.
I think all of us got turned.
That's good.
Wait, so we do the free for all now?
I think we're no, I think it's just done.
I think we went over so.
Well, they will they.
They're in the other thing, re-roll Deadpool.
They're in the other lobby.
Hmm.
I don't know if they're doing one more or not.
I'm not sure.
I think like, well, are the other teams still there?
Or are they all left?
Uh...
Moxie and Jay are here.
Everyone else left, I think.
Yeah, I think I think it's GG's.
Oh, XQC is literally already reacting to content.
he's literally gone he's on youtube right now he's on
youtube he's like he's done he literally gone that is funny
yeah ggs guys ggs guys when marvel rattles launching this
week guys yes january 16.
thank you net ease and it's for you to play thank you guang
guang thank you guang love you guang love that guy all right
peace i guess yeah ggs everyone ggs why and the ggs all
right we're still playing though we're so we're still going
i'm just gonna boot up the other marvel rivals build um
thoughts deadpool is so confusing i was literally button
mashing at the at that point i uh it is i felt like i was
just what the fuck i was doing because like it gets so
overwhelming when you're like actually playing deadpool in
the game um i just i don't know how to do it i was like when
katana or pistol oh katana pistol oh i died dead i think
yeah it's harder because like only his pistol heals unless
you slash enemies oh my god and when I don't know but his
ult his ult look it's he's but like it's doo-doo I can't
tell his ult feels pretty like like doo-doo also the gail
the me and gail curse continues to live on I think when me
and gail are on a team together we just don't win like I
don't know like it's just a curse I don't I think it's like
it's both of us like we like curse each other like like me
and gail as a team together with all and then for some
fucking reason they always put us together we're like
tournament he's a good player but like when we both are
together we like cancel each other out like we like cancel
each other out because every like and then for some fucking
reason it's like tournaments too that we get match paired up
together like we're the failure Like whenever we're both
together on the same team and, like, we have a 0% win rate
with all the tournaments and sponsored previews we've done
together is weirdly 0%.
I don't know how, I don't know why.
I don't know.
We just, we, and we've done a lot together, too.
We had like three tournaments together and like two
sponsored previews together.
And we have a 0% win rate as a team.
I will, no, no, Moxie's team was pretty stacked.
Everyone on our team are like, they're all top 500 except
for XQC, I believe.
Everyone on that team is top 500 except for XQC.
And I think only on my team, it's only Gail and Saipay, I
believe.
I think it is like Gail and Saipay that's top 500, like top
500.
And then the rest of us are just content creators.
we don't play as much anymore but we were we did pretty
close i think like um and then we were like i i did fuck
around a little bit with jeff in the first game um because i
just wanted to try out the new team up yeah i used to be top
500 back in season zero one but like we don't play as much
anymore that's the thing um all the thing is i meant like as
in like current top 500 because like i used to be top 500
season zero and one but i don't play rank as much anymore um
and the rest of us like blast used to be top 500 season zero
one child used to be top 500 season zero and one i don't
know about casey i don't really know her i think she's i
think she's like i checked her thing i think she was like
celestial i think i don't know what her peak is um but uh
moxie's team were like current lot like uh current top 500
players but i think we did pretty well we like um uh we did
like pretty well in terms of like we were able to like match
them and stuff and i did fuck around too i was just messing
i think all of us were messing around i was playing fucking
mr fantastic and getting kills he was playing mr fantastic
we're just playing characters that were sloping pat like got
like new buffs and nerfs too yeah but it was a very close
game it was very close game got that moxie bringing up the
haka he Fucking Chris A fucking Chris He brought up the hot
guy He's like It all feels Hot guy time Scott Bro his hot
guy is so fucking good Bro Like his hot guy gets banned In
the top 500 As well Yeah they literally started with Held on
Namur True Alright give me a sec I just gotta do something
super quick because I promise to grab something real quick
after I do this.
Okay, where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
Okay, partner announcement.
There we go.
I'm grabbing something for someone.
But it was fun.
It was very fun.
I had a quick time.
I assume this is it?
Yeah.
Pass it over.
Alright.
Let me see.
Alright, so I had to pass something over to someone real
quick.
Because I said I promise I do it after the sponsored
portion.
Technically this is still a sponsored portion for one more
hour.
And then, but though they know I was going to play Rivals
regardless.
They're like, are you fine with playing Rivals for another
hour?
And I was like, bro, I was going to do it for free, but
sure.
a little to think no i was actually planning on doing it for
free but yeah i take those i i was gonna get on it
regardless now i get paid yippee that's our dokey it was
really fun my team was really fun that was what i was really
nervous about um i was really nervous about my team being
super serious and being super serious and um also i'm sure
i'm sure let's start it we already had our warm-up yeah but
everyone was like super vibes because i know that moxie's
team was the vibes team uh moxie's team oh what had to be
the vibes team too where they also were messing around
because they were messing around too with different
characters um um and i was like really nervous because i
know like half the team were super serious people so i was
like oh i hope we have vibes i hope everyone has fun and we
did our team that was pretty vibey and um and i really
appreciate that team has passed the vibes check they have
they really have now we go visit my people
uh let's see wait why my practice range this is not my
people sorry now it's time to go to my people now all right
yeah oh my god we're yeah
let's go Oh my god, they're sitting on the chair.
Wait, that is so good.
No!
I don't know who has the chair, Eva!
Who did I equip the chair?
Is it Invis?
Even when the multiverse is in danger, family still comes
first.
My people, that's what I need after a long hard day.
After a long hard day, Marvel Rebels.
That's what Yeah, but I didn't equip it So that's how I was
like, which one Wait, why aren't you dancing?
I paid for this This is what they sponsored me for Let's go
No, okay The visual clutter was insane Though, like when
there was like 20 Like there was like five different alts In
front of us With like The five fucking different alts with
Deadpool and then Double Invis and then Like I don't know
there was like and then Rogue alt and That was crazy I was
like I don't Know what's going on on my screen anymore I
I don't know what to look at Alright It's time to game Wait
why do they get eternity players What the fuck If they lose
the game, they better...
If they lose the game, they better...
They better derake.
I'm like, what are they doing here?
That's why I didn't want to go inside.
You know, when we saw the ult, and then I was like, I'm not
going...
I'm not going in there.
Boom, boom.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
Sorry, just, uh, just spawns, not, uh, not the sponsor, but,
like, just other, other obligations that I have to, have to
look at.
Alright.
In this Gambit, it's always in this Gambit.
I am Loki.
Godess.
Wait, actually, I want to chill.
Sure, wait.
Wait, did you want to play?
When is this?
Oh.
I didn't say anything but Wait, wait I accidentally pressed
Enter I meant to say I didn't say anything I didn't
That's awkward.
I was trying.
Oh, fuck.
I'm not focused.
No, boy.
Oh, I'm not focused.
Okay.
That's no.
I'm off my group.
I'm off.
off my group right now.
I'm off my group.
Guys, someone's gotta help our joke, guys.
I fucking ran around.
Okay, wait.
Chair.
Okay, I'm off my groove there.
i don't know i don't know if moxie actually wants to play or
if he's i don't know but if moxie wants to play i'll play
with moxie because he did ask first and i was just too busy
and i was guys to be fair i was too busy enjoying my chair
with my show i had a dinner and a show real quick
We gotta, we gotta, oh my god.
It's the fucking Backline Shotgun Punisher player.
That's all he's gonna do.
That's all.
Look, I was in Times Square, okay?
Wait, he dropped a low eternity?
Bro.
Okay, yeah, I heard about him, because I saw him on...
I think it was Gomez's stream.
Their team's capture progress.
Yeah.
Where is my tank?
like wow no I'm looking all I'm just pressing right click
can't blame me on that I did my job I'm literally doing my
job I'm just like he right click okay he he right click
there you go I believe I don't no longer no longer but the I
know I was the only I got so lulled I refused to believe He
literally ulted just to Run at me The curse never stops What
the fuck is that
Is this winnable Okay It is so I'm just gonna It is So I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna Did he got him?
He did.
Okay, look, we gotta shoot that Loki.
Alright, that's fine.
We're doing animal crossing.
It's fine.
No, he's back.
Ow, ow!
Yeah!
Oh.
I no longer...
Are you guys all okay?
Oh my!
Where did he go?
I wasn't okay.
The thing is, that is easily counterable, but not in
Celestial 1.
Not in Celestial.
These Celestial players don't know what to do.
They're confused.
Oh my god, he back.
He back.
He surprisingly has a lot less depth than he should.
There we go.
That's all he's been doing this for like five seasons.
I think.
He's been doing it for five fucking...
Jesus Christ.
I did all I could.
Bro, okay.
Like, what can I do?
He literally...
runs at us.
I threw my stick.
Please respond.
I throw my stick.
I have a few.
Nope, there he is.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I was like.
He's sick.
Somewhere.
She's somewhere.
I was trying to find a rest.
What is that crosshair?
Bro, I literally...
There was no reason for him to be there, but he is here.
I was trying to figure out...
I was like, okay, I should put my rest.
I literally got fucked over because I wanted to put my rest
down.
I just wanted to put my rest down.
That's how unlucky I was.
that rollout should be that's what he does but he's like but
he he's always hard like not hard stuck but like he goes up
and down very crazily because um you can count on me i got a
plan ah bless me because like it's not sustainable because
he can get easily countered by um by the higher elo the high
elo is very easy to counter get ready You are too sick.
On Mag.
Yeah, it's cool.
Ravos never changes.
I will...
Ravos being Ravos.
Four, three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Who is he playing now, Venom?
Oh, maybe he's a Venom player.
It is last day of comp.
We have Iron Man.
This is last day of comp.
That's okay.
I'm not swapping off Rocket.
This does not look fun to play if I'm not Rocket.
Wait, how did like...
How did the Iron Man not...
Wait.
How did the Iron Man not get my res?
I literally put it down before he died.
I think our Iron Man did more as...
Definitely more as...
Hello, than Iron Man.
But I don't think he's playing anymore.
Our other tank was more of a tank.
To be fair, we have Moon Knight.
To be fair, I don't think we even have, like, a comp.
Like, why?
Hello,
so there is a story on foot.
But don't worry, we're coming back.
I'm extra lethal.
I don't think we have a real team.
Like, everyone's playing.
mystery hero at this point like this feels very mystery hero
this doesn't feel like real players like a cop i don't think
we're playing a real cop like who is on point that's
preventing us from i mean okay this is real what is I'm not
on it.
Oh my god, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
Ah, is he still on the point?
Alright, here we go.
Yeah.
Oh!
There she's rolled up.
He's doing his...
How?
Oh my god, please, for the love of God, at least let me be
alive.
I don't know yet, but I do feel like it's a hate crime.
All right.
I'm not sure yet.
I feel like I'm getting targeted.
I have Lord on almost all supports.
Except for...
Can we all not have Gambit?
Gambit and Jeff.
Those are the only supports I don't have Lord on.
What?
There's no... I was gonna say, if he gets a kill there, then
like, what ELO am I in?
The issue is, well, I guess I'll just...
Okay, there's no way.
Yeah, I was like, there's...
I don't know where to go.
This guy was following me.
I have...
Oh, no, I don't know.
What?
I don't know.
Adam's legs have been, like, cracked in half so many times
that...
We are undefeatable!
It's okay.
If he comes after me, I have the Angela.
I have the Mantis.
There you go.
Oh, that is unlucky.
Why?
Like, get out of here.
Oh my god.
I thought I had someone still... It's okay.
I get to be freed from this.
get to be I get to get out of this lobby we didn't want to
play another rat anyway no I I might have to avoid three
people on my team
and toothless because I bro no the thing is it's a gamble I
don't want to gamble the back line and shotgun punish here
only because it is a gamble he is good but it's so 50-50
unless you get like a good like a player that Like, he can-
he is very easily counterable.
He is very easily counterable.
Okay.
What?
Alright.
Oh, wait, I'm back in my lane.
Yay!
No, this is not good.
I gotta pick a better place.
How did it take me straight here?
In Times Square.
Ha ha ha ha.
um sad thank you for the gifting of tier one sub to the ego
thank you thank you wait is moxie even on bro moxie isn't
even on wait he is what is she playing uh
gomez what if i replace you with moxie he did ask first but
i don't know if he's doing it already because like i
accidentally wrote i did it
i'm already heading on all right we do We do a coin flip
We do a coin flip Because I don't know It is, we gotta be
fair It was first come first serve And I have not played
with Moxie Yet I'll do a coin flip Coin flip Heads will be
Moxie Tails will be It's heads
I didn't even have to finish this I don't know I don't know
yet I don't know yet
You you Do you, I want to play, though?
I...
All right.
There we go.
Oh, lazy.
Thank you for the 30 gifted subs!
I really appreciate it.
You're not even fucking on.
Gomez, you're not even...
You can't say I'm heading on when you're not even on, dude.
You're...
But lazy.
Thank you again for the 30 gifted subs.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much, guys.
Thank you.
TikTok.
White rabbit.
Let's do it.
Sorry, Gomez.
I have to give dick 20.
I'm sorry.
It's first come, first serve.
Buy his wig.
in.
Lacey, thank you for the 20 gifted, bro.
He's paying a win.
Gomez, thank you for the 20 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Lacey, thank you for the 20 gifted subs.
I really appreciate it, guys.
They turned it.
Bro, Lacey's not even, like, like, part of the, like, the
Moxie versus Gomez fight.
Unless he's fighting for Moxie.
They're actually fighting.
He's not even on, guys.
Yeah, that's Moxie's out.
He's doing it for the love of the game.
Bro, I was just saying, first come, we're equal here.
Check this card.
This is what life is doing to me at this moment.
What is it?
What shaders?
What?
Bro, just...
Bro, the game is, like, forcing him to download.
Wait, why are you downloading Marvel Rivals?
Bro, why are you downloading?
Bro, when was the last time you touched rivals?
How are you still downloading content?
That's on you.
It's on you today.
the fuck are you still he's still pro he's like stuck at 93%
that's a skill issue I think that's the world telling you
it's not time
we're waiting for Moxie right now yeah someone get this mad
fiverr internet wait he has it but he has like shitty fiverr
internet today's just not that day so Super okay.
I am not playing with that account.
I I am not playing with that account.
I am I did not I do not give you the pass.
I I did not give you that pass.
The Chinese.
He's bad.
You're not going to keep playing on that account if you're
going to play with me.
Oh, yeah.
Wow, we win.
That's Gomez's alt account, chat.
But don't worry.
As we win.
Is he even... Let's spectate this.
How is he doing?
in Celestial Year.
He's not.
He's looking Colombian.
That's the thing.
He's not.
Wait, are they attack or defense?
I can't tell.
Oh, they're defense.
Okay, they're winning.
Oh, wait.
No, they're attack.
Oh, they're losing.
Oh, feels bad.
Where he's just in the very Chinese period of his life right
now.
Okay, I don't know if you guys know about this, this, the
TikTok video.
Oh my god, a slot is this.
How many fucking accounts do you have?
But there's one of my favorite TikTok videos where...
Oh, wait, no, he's defending.
I don't know.
watch no you're gonna win okay they can win this yeah um but
it's one of my favorite videos where this guy was like puts
on the glasses where it shows um where it shows like um it
shows sorry like i said first come first serve i are you
ready yeah i'm ready let's go well let's hit bro all right
but he's like secretly yeah and then he puts out glass like
wait he's chinese he's actually chinese and then he's like
you see like everyone's secretly chinese bro i was just like
mashing buttons on deadpool i'm so confused on him yeah no
that that character is dank i don't think anyone's gonna be
playing that right yeah like like like i i don't think
anyone's gonna ban him like it takes it's gonna take so long
to actually master that guy and and it's like yeah we got
iron man in the game
yeah um and then he like was like wait this guy's secret
he's actually chinese you take a selfie you post it on like
and then he was like guys let's get chinese he's like no
guys he's secretly bro i think like have you watched the
movie wait which movie deadpool yeah yeah the that and the
sequel yeah that i hope they do the i'll do bye-bye-bye as
an emo that'd be fine is it a uh oh yeah yeah 100 that guy
like even when you i don't know you try but even when you're
afk like he also he doesn't stop talking like he's just
talking to himself you got master yeah did you know did you
know that skills transfers over when you swap between
players well we'll never find out if he knows i never knew
that yeah i didn't know that i don't even know what that
means even I do not know that fact, nor do I even know the
terms you just said within the correlation to Deadpool.
I forgot I only...
Like you upgrade the book.
Okay, I don't have group.
I don't have...
I don't have group chat, so like...
If I'm at the talk...
Okay.
Okay, but to be fair, I don't think Moxie was just playing,
like...
I don't even know if Moxie even touched Deadpool.
Now, who...
I don't have the sorry Gomez next time next time how about
this if you're still streaming after Moxie and I are done
let's let's run it
I think tank is the strongest I think support is just not it
for Deadpool I don't even know if Gomez is still watching oh
double bands
alright here we go first come first serve guys I said for
he's hate watching wait can I run an ad real quick give me a
sec I don't run ads oh shit here you go I ran an ad is he
still hate watching
oh wait he's subbed you're right it's all right guys I don't
have an ad running right now
But...
I'll do Loki.
Oh, shit.
Triple support, let's fucking go!
Speed,
thank you for the Twitch Prime, thank you, thank you!
Oh, now I have to watch an ad!
You gotta watch an ad for his crimes.
Don't lie to me.
That's right.
You got to blame Gomez for that shit.
Yeah, he made you all watch an ad.
Getting punished for other people's crimes.
Welcome to society.
I'm sad now.
I swear I'm not throwing when I pick this character.
I kind that can play sometimes maybe.
decent days i believe i don't have group i don't have group
mike i don't if he wonders why i'm typing i don't have group
voicey so i'll be talking to like people will think i'm
talking to my demons if i if i speak unlike if i speak i
want to make sure they you don't think i'm okay he's like i
swear i'm not throwing oh Okay, I think our team...
What the f- I got double pulled.
Did he double died as Spider-Man?
Yo, guys, bye, Bob.
I'm gonna be playing Cap.
All right.
Okay, I'll have to find that shit.
I'll find it later.
I just can't be bothered having two separate voice thingies.
It feels very inconvenient.
There's no reason to.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Let's go.
Oh, wait.
Actually, we should have fucking went mad.
Actually, I went mad.
How was I that fucking low?
Oh, my God.
It's butt muncher.
Oh, it's too dead.
I already made all the... Okay, he's gonna have a reset, but
That is not my fault.
I might have to swap off then.
I legitimately...
Nice.
He doesn't have shit.
I have to swap off Loki.
I know I'm sorry, everyone.
We might have to swap off Loki and go Invis.
Alright, let's go!
Walk, walk, walk!
Shit, I didn't get two people in, but fuck it.
I'll run it out, I'll run it out.
It's fine.
Where is everybody?
Alright, I'll put this out.
Alright, and then this is not good.
This is not good.
What?
Oh my god, what happened to me?
I don't even...
Oh, it's fine.
I wanted to swap off.
I got exploded.
That's crazy.
I didn't even...
Where is he?
Oh no.
I was like, where's our rocket?
I didn't even know what happened to me.
I got exploded so fast.
All right, let me fucking grab my squad, push the talk.
Where is that?
What?
How do you...
Wait, how does this work?
Oh!
I pointed at five.
Alright, you're not gonna throw now?
Not gonna throw now?
I'll try not to use this.
I need to reply to this guy.
Alright.
That's crazy.
Little did you know I was throwing.
Literally did you know I threw.
I was throwing.
I played Rocket.
Okay.
Yeah, when everyone is throwing, no one is.
Okay, I have not played in a while, though.
Jesus, everybody.
Everyone is...
Oh, he stopped.
He fucked it up.
We're dead.
It doesn't matter.
Alright, guys.
They just used a lot of ults.
Do not say GG.
They just used ults.
That's all it was.
Yeah, yeah, it's winnable.
It's winnable.
I believe.
Oh, it might not be.
Jacob, relax, man.
Relax.
We're getting way too wild.
Just chill.
The thing is, I haven't played Invis in so long.
Because like everyone fucking plays Invis.
So I never have to play Invis.
So I don't remember how to play Invis.
Like, it's not that hard, but still.
We are alive, but just us.
Guys, you can survive more on Luna.
It's a warm-up game, it's a warm-up game.
Guys, flaming him isn't gonna make him play better.
Damn, he's so PMA.
He's so PMA, guys.
Wait.
I gotta ult this.
It's okay.
It's no longer okay.
Unless!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, wait, who the fuck is?
this guy.
Oh my god, it's you and me.
It's you and me.
It's you and me, Punisher.
And you too.
Oh my god, and you as well.
It's you and me.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
I'm serious.
Never mind.
It's longer you and me i try to jump into that and it didn't
matter it's okay we have our cloak will live i believe in
the power of our club okay i don't know how they cap that
but that's okay this is a little awkward but
it's okay we can survive this we cannot survive this
Okay, it's okay.
We can survive.
Me and the thing both survived it together.
Oh,
wait.
It's okay.
We... Oh!
It's still...
Well, I hope I'm healing someone.
What the fuck?
I can't see where he is.
GG's guys.
Um...
Warm up, warm up, warm up game.
Also, JK, I was also throwing.
I was playing a different version of this game, except for a
few hours.
That's true.
We were playing a different game before.
We were... Yeah, we were...
We were playing, it's all the, we were just thinking about
season six.
That is true.
Oh, it's all right.
I didn't want to be Celestial one anyway.
It's okay.
We were, we were still in season six, right?
That's why.
We were, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Our heads were still thinking about season six.
Exactly, exactly.
Yeah.
Also, I'm banning Phoenix.
You're banning Phoenix.
Wait, why Phoenix?
Wait, why?
Characters, I don't know.
Characters will be.
I don't know.
I'm too old to play it.
Can't teach an old player new tricks, guys.
It's like kind of RNG if it hits or not.
That's true.
Yeah, it's true.
Your arrow is like 20 times a hitbox of a Phoenix hit,
right?
Yeah.
That's what I need.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, back to Times Square.
How do I get back to time square wait if i'm in time square
do i hear him do i hear him in time square it's time to find
out oh all right where are my people yes all right wait i
gotta position myself better there we go i got joe
The best day of my life.
It's all about the positioning to make sure I have the best
angle.
If he is talking to me, just let him know I'm having a show
right now.
I'm going to my show.
It is.
It is the best use.
The best use of my emote.
This is my favorite part of Rivals.
Times Square, the fact that they added Times Square.
Oh, I love watching my ads, too.
Wait, is that the future?
Oh, God.
Paul's charge.
Wait, you can thrust now?
I thought they disabled that.
They added back in.
At first, when Times Square first came out, Iron Man was not
allowed to thrust.
They, like, wait, what's that?
11 months?
Oh, it's the new Avengers movie.
But he was not allowed to thrust in Times Square.
they denied it from him
now he's free 1984.
that's okay he's he's free now he can finally be free he
added it back in just for him that's so nice
yeah he had his wings back yo what's going on team oh never
mind i was gonna i thought you were gonna bend phoenix
all right let's go
yo is this you moxie bro don't tell me you were playing cap
in my last match bro like a like a bozo let me like a bozo
like a bozo yeah was my phoenix putting belt the ass on you
be honest no no no he was he's bad he was a pussy holy ego
bro holy ego it's okay oh man i'm here to help out i'm gonna
help a hold me out
oh never mind it didn't matter it didn't matter
okay yeah i want to play loki we all wanted to play loki you
know what oh i was gonna play mantis but it holy yogurt bro
make up your mind bro you want a mag or a mantis both we run
triple we run two one three guys how about do we need this
you said what i'm just saying we're against energy so like
wait we are Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, I'm trying to feel terrorized.
What the fuck?
We're against energy.
Which one is him?
Yeah.
Don't you think?
30 seconds before you attack.
Oh, my God.
Oh, he's energy.
His number one.
He's on the number one team currently.
That one MRC.
He's on a team that one MRC.
That's what Tony used to say.
Energy.
So they got first place.
I am low key.
All right, here we go.
He'll be fine.
You egoed my friend request, Brown.
And I sent that shit with love, Brown.
I'll tell you when I call it with me, Brown.
Damn.
No, I don't want to be pretty, bro.
I just won the game.
I don't want your pretty.
All right, here.
Oh, Spidey!
Ah, here we Spidey!
Goodbye.
Thank you.
They only have one support.
M is half and the diamond.
Oh!
They don't have enough foes.
I'm just so you don't think.
Oh, someone's using the VC thing.
I just noticed it.
Okay, we got two picks here, and we're not pushing up.
We're so scared.
There we go.
Nice.
I'm not coming out of this hole.
I saw Spider-Man there.
I'm fucking not coming out of this hole.
They just don't happen to you, huh?
They have two melee, so I'm just saying no thing, though.
Wait, Spider-Man's low.
Oh, he was so low.
all right i have a lot here oh shit goodbye i got i got both
things this year this year i got double team wait okay oh my
god no i yeah no i i did not have the reaction time for the
double hit i that was crazy I did not have unfortunately I
did not have the reaction time for that what happened true
oh I didn't realize he did
how did that hit me
mag where'd you all go oh my god it's fine that's fine
that's fine that is not fine I got pushed out That is not
fun.
I literally got pushed out into that.
Are you serious?
I don't like how you bugged me out, bro.
Shit hurt my feelings.
No, they pushed me out while I was trying to up, and then I
got Spider-Man out there.
They saw the weakness.
He was actually in Sabah bully.
Oh, my God.
I have to do this because he's dying.
I was actually getting Sabah bully.
oh if i'm far away he can't hurt me right that's usually how
it goes right
apparently not apparently not where where it was my invis
where the fuck was he
i felt like i was like in the center Like with everyone
except
Don't worry.
I got you Okay, I literally saved his life.
Come right come right come right come right come right come
right come right where we're going right We're going here
Bro Yeah, I'm not fucking get away from stupid there you go
oh that's unfortunate watch those five people that's five I
juke did enough characters working oh my god I jukeed it oh
my god jukeed it thank god time to vanish I'm so paranoid
right now
backing up a little I'm way too paranoid about this
we're fine we're so healthy I kept my invas I did my job I
kept him alive I did my job and then I don't know okay you
sure what's There's no way to keep you alive.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, what the fuck hit me?
I was like, what hit me there?
Where is my thing?
Oh my god.
They're up inside.
I don't know what hit me, but like, what's hitting me?
What is hitting me?
I had to TV.
I got scared.
I got touched.
I was like, I'm gone.
I'm gone.
Math is haunted.
It's a fucking haunted by...
I'm haunted by the enemies I killed.
A ghost touched me and I got scared.
30 seconds before you attack get ready there you go i gotta
take my meds guys i'm going crazy
i'm going crazy right now i'm hearing voices they're getting
touched by a ghost oh yeah i need to change the title it's
not it's not Deadpool anymore.
There's Lady Loki.
There's Loki time.
Where are we going?
Hot ground?
Was he not going hot ground?
Wait, he's not going.
Well, they're not going hot ground.
Where do I go?
Hello, hello, one.
Number one.
Okay.
There we go.
I had to.
Yeah.
You already copied?
It's fine.
We won it because of my copy, guys.
Oh, I'm on triple sub now.
Guys, we won because of my copy.
Just so you know.
Wait, what the fuck?
my copy saved us you're welcome
which one's the oh fuck that's well guess that was the real
one I was like which one's the real Loki he found me he
found me oh that is very unfortunate of course I'm trying to
He'd be away from the Spider-Man and then the Emma Ultz in
front of me.
That truly was I'm like, do I want to die from the
Spider-Man or do I want to die from the Emma Ultz?
Truly truly a very unfortunate time.
Damn.
Very unfortunate.
Alright.
It's just Spider-Man players.
I feel like everyone wants to play i feel like in like it's
just he's like the he's like the junk rat the junk rat of
all right
it's fine nice grab all right here you are i'm okay oh there
you go everything one is everybody's okay right I'm not one,
I'm not one.
Everyone's okay.
I have no level.
Yeah, I was not risking that.
I had no...
I had no Invent.
Ah, fuck.
What?
That's okay.
He's low.
I have many faces.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, he's on beam.
Oh.
What a bother to leave.
Spotty diff.
Oh, nice.
He actually spotty diffed him.
Big comms.
Good comms.
Spotty diff.
Nice.
I hear I'll spot him, man.
No, it's gonna be...
I will not trust anybody that locks in Deadpool.
Like, I will not trust you.
Oh.
You'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner.
Leave them to Kanshu I'm sorry Oh shit Oh shit Hey we did it
Yeah Bullshit team We did it Let's go Come on Hi Moxie We
did it We beat the NA DPS champion That means we are the NA
champions Exactly We beat them so technically we are better
That's the rules, right?
That's the rules.
Like how we beat Saipa, we become rank number one.
We take it straight.
Yeah, we fucking...
If you win MRC and then like...
If you win MRC and then you get beat by someone in a random
rank battle, Gwanga comes over, kicks your door down, ticks
your trophy.
Because you're like, Capy rank one, if you lose the...
You can't be rank one if you can't win every game.
That's on you.
It makes him look bad.
As it should be.
You keep what you kill.
That just makes everyone look bad.
Yonk my trophy now.
Lose to a V2 for GG's.
Alright, back to my favorite place.
Oh, I like how it's automatic timescreen.
He knows what I want to do.
Oh my god.
And then it spawns me back to where I was before.
It literally keeps my location.
Wait, I have two?
Wait, there we go.
Keep.
Keep going.
It's okay.
I have this guy.
Let's grab a backup.
Always have backups.
Always have.
Always have backup, guys.
Wait, what's this guy's name?
What's his name?
Brack, come here.
I need a show.
Wait,
this guy is bigger.
You ain't paying.
He's not dancing.
Why is he not dancing?
What's the point?
At least I have him.
This is Captain America.
I like the angle for this one.
Let me take a sip just like Invis.
What's the point of being a big venom if you don't own the
twerk?
That's Stolen Valor.
That is Stolen Valor right there.
You might as well play something.
You might as well be someone else.
William DeFleu looking I was like
that's enjoying my time who am I gonna banish from this
match
BAM time can we ban Gambit second
I still have like I still have like All right.
Oh, we have a...
We have a...
Jeff!
What am I streaming tomorrow?
Guys, what's our schedule for tomorrow?
It's Project Zomblet.
Oh, brainstorm ideas.
Okay.
Alright, Gambit, Gambit.
Alright, what do I...
Rocket.
Animal Crossing tab.
Brainstorm and then...
Uh...
The Project Zomblet.
Oh yeah, do I have any...
member goons from the project's on boy server is it okay now
i looked at it and it didn't need a restart i saw people
were on it so i assumed everything's fine i was about to
restart the server because of the mods the mods weren't
update we're up we're not like matt auto updating
so like i wasn't sure any goons who are any member goons
that are on the server on the project Xombo server?
Is it okay?
Or do I need to, like, fix it?
Massive group.
You have to team up.
Best team up in the game.
This is a weird cop.
This is truly the last two days of rank.
Uh, tank, do you care if I eat your old- Oh, you can log in?
Okay, then it should be fine.
The server should be okay.
Yeah!
Do you care if I eat your old face-to-portal?
Two, one!
Thank you.
All you need to do is capture the missionary.
it's okay they have a phoenix but it's okay i can swap off
it's not now
oh that's unlucky i was about to throw in my oh i might need
a swap oh all right uh
okay but i really don't want to The thing is, I really don't
want to play Luna into this.
What the fuck?
I mean, it's...
Oh, you got res, though.
We didn't get a kill.
That is a fast all of us, though.
For sure.
Alright, I think this guy is better at...
This guy might be better at Moon Knight than you.
Oh, maybe.
He might be...
He might be different.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Hey, I'm MVP.
Let's go.
I'm...
Hey, I'm MVP.
Don't...
Can we not run Rocket Joe?
No.
I have all...
I'll stop.
Can we go on the left side and try and take the not main?
All right.
There's Luna jail time.
There's Luna jail.
I don't need my...
Whoa!
Yeah, no, he fucking did.
No, that guy is dead.
Yeah, I have my luck, though.
Really close?
From one mag out to the next?
At this point, you should go lucky.
I would just...
that i'm sorry to tell you all right
oh he up he did fuck it up i would oh my god here let's go
oh let's just use everything let's go okay um maybe i can
freeze it watch this i went the wrong way watch oh my god i
watched this it's too late it's too late okay okay did you
guys watch it they fucking locked the door what was that
supposed to do guys it's not i haven't done it yet i haven't
you gotta keep watching you gotta keep watching I haven't
done the thing I was gonna do.
Keep watching.
Watch this, guys.
Watch this.
See, see, see, we haven't.
We're not done yet.
Did you see that?
Did you see that, though?
Not this, though.
Not this.
He's gonna kill me.
He's, oh, wait.
I'm fine.
I got that freeze.
That freeze was sick.
That was a sick-ass freeze, though.
I told you.
you oh that's unfortunate you're down i get away you watch
it i told you it was sick
oh my god get over get over no get over get over okay okay
we all have to get together oh my oh my god okay
All right,
that's fine.
It's okay.
It happens.
You know another DPS or another roll by any chance, Malkai?
It's okay.
No, maybe.
Give me a second.
Let me cook.
Yeah, he's cooking.
He's cooking.
Oh my god.
I looked at him when he said I need healing.
so that's not on me.
I did look at him.
What?
Okay.
Wait.
On my end, my right click went off.
My right click went off.
I would have died regardless, but my right click went off
there.
Yeah, and it didn't hit him.
That should have been a hit right there.
Well, our guy can up now because, like, he should be able to
up now.
to her to this guy okay mine okay i will say my frames are
dying i will say though but i don't like that
okay that should kill everything not gonna lie that all
right that's fine 88 i literally need please cloak please
i'm 93 and i need this all really badly okay i got it okay
um our mag didn't have bubble all right Dude, hop back, come
on!
Uh, can we pull?
Guys, I swear I'm trying to get him to know my soul again!
It's that actually is, Moxie.
What the fuck, bro?
Do you, Moxie?
I believe in you, Moxie.
It's okay, he asked me to believe in him.
Oh,
I should not have went in there.
Oh, see?
He did it!
He's doing it!
See, I told you, I can...
Bro, I'm getting...
I'm telling you, this is not...
It's very well.
Maxi, it's a...
Okay.
Moxie's kid.
I believe in you, Moxie.
He do.
Yeah, we believe in him.
I mean,
he's gonna go rocket.
I'm gonna go Loki.
Okay.
Do you know another dude?
DPS?
I do.
Guys, I'm telling you, believe it or not, this might be my
best DPS.
I know that's your best DPS, but you're kind of selling my
shit, bro.
No, the score line is not accurate.
You're gonna have to prove it.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Guys, if we all believe in him, maybe he'll do better.
It's his best character.
Let him cook.
Guys, let him cook.
You're letting a controller player have more Elims than you.
Can't allow it.
Guys, why am I being heckled right now?
We're all on the same team.
I want to see you lock in.
Use it.
You have to stop them from securing the missionaries.
Doom has overreached.
I'm gonna go down because I feel like yeah oh my I see look
we just got a one's gonna say anything about that I have my
res back in 20 no one's gonna say anything I have my res
that's crazy guys he has those res that's crazy
Oh my god, did he grab this?
What?
Okay, I was gonna say...
I'm old in a few seconds.
I'm at 90.
We have like we need it.
Oh, that's crazy.
I'll get first counter roll.
When Phoenix olds, can we all focus it?
Alright, here we go.
I have a two.
I have shift soon.
Oh.
I can alt that once they fail.
Mag and backline.
Choke is Munich.
Okay, we did.
There we go.
They're inbound, inbound, inbound.
Yes, I didn't have to.
Let's go.
yeah let's kill boxy oh my god just need to see just need
people to believe guys i told you the more you believe the
better he does it's like fairies if you stop believing they
die it's fairy law uh mag going right he might try and swing
be careful it's literally fairy law What?
Uh.
What is he doing there?
All right, there we go.
I can't see you where you are, sir.
Thanks.
I was gonna say, what the fuck was that?
I'm just gonna let a rocket heal.
He doesn't need my heals.
I was back in ten.
Fuck it.
Oh.
Hogamoto.
Teamplay.
Relay.
That's five.
Uh, res is down.
Oh.
Strange one.
There you go.
He gets five.
Uh, I'm dead.
You're down on the torch.
I still need you.
Oh, Bucky won, Bucky won.
Do we want me to portal?
No, we should be good.
Uh, I can't.
It's even, it's even.
I think we're fine.
I'm just going to come back and drop it.
I hold when I get back.
Let's just hold.
I get old.
Togi's feeding salt when it comes up.
You know nothing.
Togi's feeding salt.
All right.
You are a storm.
You got this, Hawkeye.
Oh my god, I'm trying my best to heal everybody.
There you go.
It's me and you.
It's so winnable!
Look at that!
I- Go get Venom.
You better run on me?
Bro, I'm fucking, I'm trying, buddy.
I am a try Where is the support for me to copy where?
I swear to God I'm waiting for okay, it's fine.
I'm gonna copy anything.
All right, see?
See I was like I want it worse.
I'm not copying Jeff
Cap is that sure I'm gonna copy cap and just go.
America.
See?
We got it.
I always believed.
We fucking did it, guys.
You just gotta believe.
Hey, we're back here, Celestial One.
Nice.
Uh, students, thank you for the tier two sub.
Army, thank you for the tier one sub.
If we're not getting top 500, guys.
Oh, back.
We're back to uh was able that the demise needed to join
into the server oh so okay um all right we got oh this is
not the one i want to go we gotta leave we gotta reroll we
gotta reroll okay let me fix the zombie server you don't
have to say after that what what if people can't have
someone at their worst they can't have them at their best,
you know?
But what if, like, what if them heckling you motivated you
to prove them wrong?
No, what?
They, they, yeah, but then you're like, I, I'm not, I, I can
prove them wrong.
And then you locked in.
Look at that.
You got like 5K, you got like a 5K.
You're like, like, with your tears in your eyes.
Tears that are running down my face.
Yeah, yeah.
But you're like so motivated.
You're like, I'll prove them.
I, I, I can do this.
it was like a heckle yeah let's just bully everyone yeah
yeah see yeah it was a heckle buff yeah i mean like i felt
like you know if they didn't heckle you you wouldn't have
been able to pull off the kills you pulled off because at
first you know how in the beginning during like attack they
were so nice to us and they're like no don't worry moxie you
you can do this you can do and then that didn't do it yeah
and then you didn't do it and then they turned it around and
they did like good cop back cop on you you got a point yeah
yeah yeah yeah some more bullying people fix exactly
bullying works but only in rivals only around don't do it
outside of rivals Only in rivals.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, only in rivals.
Yeah, yeah.
Guys, disclaimer, it only works in rivals.
It only works in rivals.
Yeah, I was able to preview it.
Alright, let me...
Only in rivals.
Hey, when I get pulled in rivals, I stream.
So technically it worked for them.
Okay.
What did I want to do?
Oh, yeah, I want to change my title.
No, it doesn't work in Riot because you get banned if
you're...
If you say one mean thing.
Back to doing queuing.
There you go.
Yeah, like, in...
In...
In League, apparently, even you, like, decide to pick a
throw character in League, and...
game actually get cancelled and then you get like suspended
i think or warned or some i don't know you guys saw that
tweet but someone in league was reported somebody for like
picking support when they were supposed to be mid-lane and
then the match closed and was like due to someone disrupting
the match we closed the game before the game even started
because they considered them throwing because they picked
the wrong character if they had that in rivals like we would
never have a game a fucking game if they did that in rivals
kiyumi mid is viable yeah it feels like every who like
technically you could say every character is a throw
uh i mean i think i want to play i mean we're playing rocket
uh invis there's no point there's no reason to not live i
thought to be fair in my head i thought invis was bad
already normally she is so i didn't expect invisible
invisible woman to like actually be free i'm so used to her
being bad yeah i need to close something and i'll get more
flames now
oh yeah i love that i love how people are like so so they
can't say anything now that um they just say jump to bm
because they can't say anything they're like what do i say
to not get banned and they're like uh we say here now wait
is that rocket okay yeah he is
I'm so not used to being able to play in this like I said
Everyone plays in this so I never play in this so when I get
to play in this I'm like how do I play her again?
I always have to remember how to do my pulls correctly
Already holy shit All right, he's fine You're fine.
We're so healthy.
You know what?
Oh, shit!
Okay, he's so healthy.
I mean, we could just back up, right?
Jesus Christ.
Just back up.
Oh.
I don't know what happened to him.
Yeah, I pulled him back to us, though.
Bro, he's so low.
I assume.
Rocket, let's face.
all right i cannot jump um i hope everybody's okay in there
they were not
oh my god jokes on us they were not okay in there i was like
i hope i hope they're okay disclaimer they were
unfortunately very much dead
I mean, I can technically...
Oh my god, put me back in.
Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike.
Okay, Emma should have...
Oh.
Oh, I forgot about Starlord.
I should have saved it for Starlord.
That...
That is a throw for me.
I didn't...
Oh, we did not.
I forgot they had a Starlord.
That was definitely a throw for me.
It's okay.
They don't they didn't say anything Okay, I'll keep my invis
for starlord I forgot about that I was like no we should
find the push-up right and I was like oh shit wait They have
a starlord though That's my bad.
I've been brain-rided from God of War Don't uptrack no more
I don't uptrack I just I'll play video games when I can.
Oh, shit.
I don't know who is.
Oh.
Are we healthy?
Whoa.
Can't get me.
Oh, whoa.
I think he got me.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
To be fair.
We are not getting that.
Oh, no.
Rocket.
No.
Oh, he made it.
Okay, now save for Starlord.
Now I know.
Okay, I saved his life.
You're welcome.
Oh.
That's not good when a DPS swaps to triple support.
That's never a good sign.
I'm never That's never a good sound
Oh I can't Oh That's never We were all in a corridor I'm
saving your life Don't worry It's just us three supports in
the corner be fine right we are not fine we are not fine i
am trying my best to keep him alive anyone anyone come on
okay we can all in technically all right it's okay we could
use i can die
it's okay I'm saving it I have so much restraint it's okay I
have so much restraint but
who do we all who's holding next wait wait wait rocket you
can alt next it's fine yeah rocking you rocking you okay
it's fine It's past the thing.
We're okay.
I still...
Boom!
Restraint!
Buddy!
That's right!
Look at that restraint right there!
That's right.
If all else fails, we always have triple support.
Whoa.
If we lose triple supporters, that way.
Anything damage, thanks.
I'm going to let...
Okay, he's taking a lot of damage, though.
Nice.
I'm a little worried, because I think there is...
Oh, that's a lot of damage that he's taking.
Oh.
Oh Here you go You need to be on this.
Oh, I fucked it up.
I fucked it up.
I fucked it up But what do we do first?
Okay But What were you doing first?
Mimi, okay, Mantis.
All right Mantis I do it last
there you go use that to your advantage well it's gone now
like that's as much as you can use
oh oh my god i can't see
Oh, goodbye.
It's fine.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I lived.
I lived.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I lived.
I lived.
Oh, my God.
Oh, here we go.
Round three.
Oh, my God.
We have.
Whoa.
All right.
What?
Okay.
I did the best I could.
It's okay.
we have hello okay he's trying his best to say oh I got an
idea why would anyone want I'm coming over that's the best I
could do okay oh my god I just had four people run at me.
I just had four people run at me.
Holy shit.
That was a lot.
I didn't want to ult next because, um, because I knew the
mag at all and he was just gonna slam like i don't know guys
he's just gonna slam dunk me but okay okay
that's i was like oh i don't know are you sure i should be
next
i want to be like throw them we'll give you a friend but
that's that's colluding i don't endorse that guys stop
having an ego
I won't I won't You said I won't Did you just said I won't?
Yes, bro, he's right you have an ego bro
What if oh what if it's birthday
they might they heard me say what if and they're like what
if what
they'll never know they'll never know what i was trying to
say
oh that's unlucky wait that guy oh my Oh my god, that guy
was so nice, we got him.
Bro, everyone's taking so much damage.
Oh my god, there is a daredevil behind us.
I didn't even notice.
Nice.
Oh my god, he was so low too.
But...
Let me do your rocket first.
Oh.
Oh shit, we got Groot!
He's Grooting!
Nice.
Wait, not nice.
Not nice, they're still alive.
Hey guys, they are...
Alright, I was gonna say, this Daredevil is alive for a
while.
Alright.
I mean, my god could just...
Oh shit.
No, he's fucking dead.
I know that guy's dead.
He's not coming back.
Alright, let's hope they live.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, get him away from me!
It's okay.
They used 20 ults though.
They used 20 ults.
It's fine.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, that was unlucky.
I couldn't see.
I got blinded by the smoke.
What's going on?
Oh my god.
Wait, he's still... Wait, he's gone.
Wait, we're Where did he go?
I was like, I saw a tree there and you just- The tree
disappeared!
I swear there was a tree here!
I think I pushed someone out of y'all, I'm not sure though.
Nice?
Again?
Wait.
Amateur right?
there we go yo moxie oh that's point point point i had to
use it
oh no i have to reload tree no my tree there you go oh no oh
nice oh yay there's no way i died to this right like i can't
see, but there's no way.
Yeah.
Nice.
We got all up.
Oh my god.
We already played.
What is going?
This entire team is playing Mystery Heroes.
Like, like, now they're, now they're Blade.
Blade, Namedmore.
Like, what's going on?
I'm playing Mystery Heroes right now.
Oh my god.
You are so...
so healthy.
You are absolutely healthy.
Got to go downstairs.
Oh, I hope, I hope Scylok is okay up there.
I'm fucking taking the shield to rewind now.
It's rewind time.
There's no way.
That was sick!
He blocked the whip is left oh my god get back in here get
back in here get back in here oh my thank god okay you got
back in wait that's all of them
wait again again again again okay i got my i got my push
ready i'm ready where's Wait, how?
I pushed them!
But I pushed them!
Oh god.
Oh no, no!
No!
Oh, that's unlucky.
I tried to back away.
It's clear I'm still needed here.
I couldn't back away.
I was trying to leave that was so fast though i thought oh i
thought i had the push ready
no push unfortunate okay that that must have fucked him over
he was ready though he was ready oh i don't have shield
unfortunately okay I can fucking...
Yes.
Again!
What?
Oh fuck!
Oh no, we're...
That's my bad.
Give you.
I cannot stop her, guys.
I cannot die.
Oh my god.
I touched it though.
I touched it.
Oh!
I have to go...
We do have...
We have siloed up.
Wait.
Okay.
This is the best I can do.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking KB?
Oh my god, that low-key thing helped save this life.
Please, live!
Live!
I have shift suit
Please live Oh god Where's my That's me We did it Time to
switch it up Including which side you're on Okay, it's okay
a book it is it is winnable um i don't know if i should i
feel like i should stay in viz it is it is winnable we got
this it
does work i believe as long as we all believe it works it's
like fairies like i said if you stop believing we lose and
it's gonna be your fault chat
streamers never take responsibility for anything
oh it's our yes
it's because you didn't believe what did i do not believe in
me i believe yeah but it has to be a unified belief if one
person stops believing it's stops working.
Ultra.
They have healer.
Yeah, I'm like, Ultra.
That's new.
I swear to God, it's like, it's so hard to heal like all of
these fucking walls.
oh that's not good that is not good get over here matt oh my
god okay that's fine okay lead one lead one
okay lead one your powers are mine jesus christ we do not
have We got a big we got to go before they do blade combo
All right I cannot talk with me okay Oh my god, please
please Finish one finish one finish one finish one nice
Okay, there we go We still have two support We still have
two support outs.
There we go.
The current score is three, two, three.
Time to switch things up.
See, it's just about believing.
Jesus Christ.
This is a stressful fight.
One more round.
these games are way too close.
I tried too much.
What happened to my end of season chill games?
Why are all these games so hard?
What Elo is this?
It's eternity slash celestial one.
They have Vinny, guys.
Yeah.
Why is Maxi not on Hawkeye?
Because we cyber bullied him off of Hawkeye.
I cannot see It's a real moxie.
Yeah, we're doing Chillin.
First duo
Oh, they think they're healing.
Okay, maybe storm moon night storm moon night, maybe All
right Let's go
Damn, they're going full meta right now.
Yeah, I think they'll break that nest They're actually going
Jesus Christ.
I'm fucking trying to look at everybody right now.
Oh, holy shit.
I'm pushing him back.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Groot, Groot, Groot.
Oh.
We're gonna TP by the way.
Damage boosting.
Oh, MLO, MLO!
There we go.
Yay!
We did it!
Four, two, three.
Oh, I was talking in squad chat.
Oh!
Nice.
We did it.
yeah be fair it's because they went triple tank and then
like they can't do anything when we swap instantly like they
can't do anything when we hard count a triple tank like
that's the bad like it wasn't that close then there's
nothing you can do dark world thank you for the tier one so
thank you thank you well you should add the guy and then
remove them you know what you should do you should add that
guy and then remove what you're cooking yeah yeah let him
see that he's on your friends list and then remove and let
him see you disappear from the friends list i'm gonna send
him a message i'm gonna send him a message that's so evil
let's see him disappear My evil, oh, she, you monsters,
like, my, never meet your heroes.
Never, that's a sign.
You should never meet your heroes.
Streamers are evil.
Yeah.
He's learning a lesson right now.
streamer is really real villains
exactly it's a lesson okay i'm teaching this guy a valuable
lesson in life never put your idol on a pedestal i gotta pee
but don't worry you know what happens you get a free show
all right be right back i gotta use the bathroom
which hero do you think you want to be today
running back justin time yeah perfect timing
it's not a joke yeah no i would say rivals is like the
gooner the gooner hero shooter it knows what it is and i'm
all for it and knows what it is and i don't i'm i am the
target audience
uh melody thank you for the raid thank you thank you i hope
you've had a great stream thank you thank you for those who
rated me before i'm sorry if i didn't see the rate but thank
you all for the raids guys and thank you all for the subs um
and the bitties and in the follows.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah, we're playing some rankeroonies.
Bump.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Do I have any messages out of the...
Alright, it's fine.
I just want to be sure.
You know what they are and I'm okay with it.
Hey, do you want to play Envis or am I playing Rocket or are
you playing Envis or Rocket?
What are you gonna do?
I'm playing Rocket.
I don't want to.
It's my turn to chill.
I was like, I let you, I'm playing Rocket.
It's after trying so hard, it's my turn to chill.
I'm going to a gunfight.
Auto-lock with your big gun.
Okay, you guys were called dragoons before gooning was even
a word.
We, like, we transcend goons.
Literally, we were named before gooning was even a thing.
Yeah, you guys were gooning before it was cool.
go ahead oh squirrel girl bro is that guy gonna be okay yeah
he's gonna be okay oh angela oh it's the rocket otp too we
have the it's okay we have a phoenix it's a they also have a
phoenix but we don't have to worry about that doing the
right okay if i get rid i'm gonna get rid of this and no
one's gonna die brett there you go do no one oh shit oh my
god tapped out i tapped out bro i got jump scares so hard i
tapped out i
I was just like, oh my god, what the fuck was that?
Kill him, kill him.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You can't say diff win.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
That's, I don't think I'm not gonna let her have it.
I was gonna say, I don't think it's a diff win.
Five people shot at it.
Rock it up.
That's crazy.
I was.
I was not.
I'm not in the cart.
Oh, help me.
Okay.
Oh, break it, break it, break it.
I mean...
I jumped up.
Who fucking shot it?
Okay, if I do this, I need people to shoot at it.
Okay, someone shot the ult.
There was no way he's able to do that much.
Okay.
It's okay.
He gets res.
All right.
If I up this...
All right, we gotta shoot the Phoenix ult.
Kill him, kill him, kill him.
We gotta shoot the Phoenix out when I do this.
Oh,
we did not shoot the Phoenix out.
Alright.
It's okay.
It's fine.
It's a good effort.
It was a good effort.
It was a good effort, guys.
It truly was.
It's okay.
That is one res to some...
Okay, never mind.
Let me get rid of...
I clicked E and I spammed E.
Ooh.
That is unlucky.
Yay!
Okay, we're up to...
Why are we so scared?
There we go.
I ain't no coward.
Yo, Invis on the far flank, right?
Invis on far flank, right?
It's gonna be flanked deep yet.
I ain't no coward.
I got you there.
Okay, there's five.
That's five.
We're so healthy.
Look at us.
Look at us, go.
We're so healthy, guys.
Look at that.
How is he still here?
Holy shit.
Okay, that Invis is throwing.
That's...
Bro, oh my god.
Alright, Invis is still behind us.
He's still there.
He's still thinking, chilling.
i assume it oh my god he fucking um oh shit i'm coming ready
to overthrow a king let's do this one in this all right
they're running triple support now to be fair they're
running dual support they're
because it's technically dual support oh unfortunately
nobody sacked that i might even suck that healing bro you
saw that rocket right
i will have to admit i did walk away instead of stacking
There we go.
It's okay, Moxie.
He gets Rez.
It's okay, I believe.
You know what?
Come here!
The current score is...
No, that Invis is definitely throwing.
He trolling.
Did he got the double solo at?
Oh.
No, it's never.
Yeah, the one woman army.
His team just doesn't know how to walk up with him.
True.
I wanted that.
Yeah, I'm saying that Invis.
The Invis is making space
He's doing it Like is that not mental illness?
What?
Yeah
Guys if we if we should talk him more he may be he'll start
he'll he's gonna start trying we can't let him have that
He's literally TTK What the fuck with the TTK dude?
Oh, yeah, no, they're they're done Guys oh wait no oh wait
no the spider-man threw him off.
Okay i was gonna say now you got spider man you got scooter
man
there we go we start i hear him i hear a footsteps of uh of
a woman i fucking knew it i i was like i hear footsteps of a
white woman I hear I hear the clicky-clack use woman
detected my gamer senses were tingling it's like do I hear a
woman she's right behind me isn't she?
But he's like 1v1ing and he lost.
It's okay.
They got born again.
He's coming back.
It's just in your head.
They're not silly dokey.
They're not real.
Women aren't real.
It's all in your head.
Oh shit, don't have a second res.
Oh shit.
Oh no, I hear woman.
My woman senses are tingling again.
Oh my god, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
You get...
Really?
He came for me!
That guy actually went for me.
That's crazy.
i'm sorry buddy don't worry okay they are so far from us
they're not even at point
okay that's on me i guess that's not me for not expecting
it's okay i have a rocket up we just live
okay I don't know.
Shiza.
Nope.
That's unlucky.
Oh my, why is he here?
Oh my god.
No.
The woman got me again.
It's okay.
If someone dies, I have this.
I have...
It's okay.
We got this.
Watch this.
Okay, not yet.
Not yet.
Don't watch it.
CC, look, we're winning.
That's what I wanted you guys to watch.
My team.
Because this is a team game.
Did you watch it?
Did you watch the team?
Okay, she's the infant is back here.
Oh wait, no, it's the Adam.
That's not a woman.
Wait a minute.
That wasn't a woman.
Bro, I'm just like, maybe.
bro there's no way there's no way he came for be still holy
fuck and there's no way you're losing to him all right it's
fine oh my god i made it not not her though she she made it
too
She also made it.
It was after me, bro.
Like, goodbye.
Watch this.
Wee!
All right, there wee!
All right, there we go.
The juice.
I told you I got this.
But they hate you.
There you go.
It's that easy.
They want me so bad.
Oh.
That was scary for her.
Yeah, they want me.
Don't worry, I'll stay up here.
here i don't know if you live but it's okay someone one of
us will live it's okay one of us will not them though not
them but one of us will live that's okay oh my god don't
fight okay it's fine yeah i'm good go go go go by the eye of
Oh!
It's okay.
Okay, it's him.
It's a zoning out.
Yeah.
They got one.
They got scared.
Yeah.
What just happened?
Um...
It is avoiding time.
Team flaming me.
Okay.
Don't worry, I got it.
Alright, don't avoid me.
Yeah, I gotta avoid the flanking.
Yeah, and then they both started flanking too.
And then that's where it got a little crazy.
Yeah, welcome to end of season games.
You never get off this wild ride.
Bro, that guy is 8-16?
Bro, that wasn't even the Invis.
Oh, that was the Squirrel Girl.
Emma.
Oh, shit, bro.
That guy died 16 times on Emma and Squirrel Girl.
Okay, that's a little embarrassing.
Yeah.
Bro, that guy, all he did was flank and he only got 10k
damage.
He does have 8 final hits, which is the same as the other
DPS, though.
I will have to admit.
He did get eight final hits.
Yeah.
No, he soloed his own games.
How when it does...
Oh my god, it ends in one...
No, that...
Yeah, that seems right.
This does seem like end of season lobby.
It's...
Yeah, no.
These are end of season games.
100%.
That one Asian.
They give the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
They give the tier one sub.
What's the special shiny?
Oh, yeah, I forgot to check.
What is it?
Is it customized?
I haven't tried for it in so long.
Oh, it's a chess icon.
Oh, I didn't see next season.
I mean, I could die.
I'll just, someone else will post about it.
It's a chess piece.
The dragon is the coolest one, though.
Guys, what is the, what's the special shiny icon for next
season, guys?
What is it?
Because I didn't look at it.
I just looked at the funny.
I just looked at the funny stuff when I did the early Axis.
And the triple Deadpool bad.
I feel like.
I do feel like.
I think Deadpool.
Is not going to get bad.
Because he's so complicated.
I think like after people figure him out.
Everyone's going to ban him.
like Wolverine because like at first everyone was like oh
Wolverine is such a fucking throw pick and it because no one
knew how to no one knew how to play Wolverine back then and
then when people figured out Wolverine he became like like
they didn't do anything them um they didn't do like any
actual like nerfs or buffs to him people just were like oh
shit that's how you play Wolverine and then like and then
everyone just banned him I think the moment people figure it
out DPS and tank, I don't think he's a support.
I don't think support is gonna get bad.
Is eternity lobbies?
Oh, shit, we're in the big boy club.
Four feet nine, 450 pounds.
Yep, that's an eternity lobby.
I think Rivalis has the best names.
People are so creative with rival names.
Oh, hey, thank you for gifting us up to Dorky Bird.
Thank you, thank you.
Do we have a Loki player?
I mean, besides, actually, we have a Gambit player.
I play Loki.
Oh, fuck me, then.
Alright, we can go.
Yeah, we have a Gambit player.
I play this.
You are the...
What the fuck?
Bro, he's...
He's...
Okay, that's funny.
He's like, oh, wait, I'm the Gambit player.
Oh, we guess we don't have Gambit or Loki.
You know what that means.
God damn it.
Never mind.
I was like, you know what that?
Oh, okay.
It's Luna.
I didn't think he'll pick Rocket.
Bro, he plays Gambit.
You assume he would play fucking Luna.
Luna, time.
I feel like like i don't know if you're a lord gavin you
don't want to fucking play rocket i play rocket because i
don't care i want to i want to put the least effort possible
to win i still put effort but i get to put less effort than
i do play luna
yeah yeah i'm here to min max here that's why i'm a meta
slave i'm a filthy min max here
What?
Yeah, I don't have to aim.
Where the fuck is my daredevil?
There we go.
Wait, is he dead?
He does not need to know that I missed my two shots.
I have an excuse.
I haven't played this in a while.
Oh my god.
Look, I...
on rocket the last game that's my excuse please have mercy i
was on rocket last game what the fuck okay oh my god they're
running triples up to be fair we oh my god please oh my i'm
sorry i'm sorry there's too much going on
all right it's fine look i gotta get back into groove of
things okay i just i gotta get back into it i just oh my god
i i am healing you i need you to know that i i am healing
you i all i
I can't out heal.
I can't out heal all of that, though.
Unfortunately.
That was a lot.
How are they Burma healing front line?
That's a good question.
Marking there.
Flank, Jeff.
I'm going to try not to mark him this time, though.
You guys can deal with that.
I'll try to dive the backline more.
That is true.
Like there is a backline jet for some...
Oh, where is he?
Oh my god.
You
got a Luna.
I fucking...
Oh my god.
He... I saved my rocket just to get eaten.
Just to get eaten by him.
I saved his life and it was not worth it.
hold high at least I have the song to vibe to it definitely
is like a nerf it
definitely is a nerf like right after since like I haven't I
haven't played bro there's no way it comes for me I'm gonna
help this I was not...
I was mispositioned like crazy.
I had to ult that because I was not positioned, right?
It was my...
It was my get out of jail free card.
He's coming.
The chef is coming.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh.
That'll be more.
Oh, my God.
He's like, oh, I'm fucking, I'm gonna die.
And then he just subs as Joe.
I hate that.
I hate, like, I wish, like, the...
I need healing for supports.
Like, the warning thing is not, like, for one damage.
I'm gonna let...
Oh, I was gonna say I'm gonna let him heal more.
But I'm also worried.
Because we do need the other element more.
I'm gonna try and DP this thing.
Oh, I got it.
You guys will hope.
Oh my god, I almost killed him.
The Jeff literally, oh Okay Don't mess with the amazing
spider-man
I saved your life
Oh, that is very unfortunate.
Oh, we're fighting.
We're fighting.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm coming back.
Oh, whoa.
Okay, I...
Okay.
I want it.
Whoa.
There was nothing I could do.
I was trying to save our daredevil.
I was so confused.
I thought he was going to come over.
I'm so fucking confused.
That was a very confusing fight.
I was like, don't worry.
I'll come save you if you're going to.
I can go blind.
Nobody's there.
I will say that was a very confusing fight.
Because I assumed that he was going to push up and then he
disappeared.
He was, he literally disappeared in front of my eyes.
I will say that was a very shitty Luna up, but they don't
have to know that.
Please.
There's no way.
It's me and the other support.
Let's go.
Me and the other support balloting it up.
Okay.
Switch things up, including which side you're on.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Guys, I'm going- I'm getting right back into it.
Look, it might look very ugly in the beginning, but...
Also, the alt was pretty ugly.
But like, I'm getting back into the groove, okay?
Like, I'm slowly getting back into it.
It's okay.
The alt needs a little work.
But everything else, it's fine.
Okay.
It's fine.
Yeah, winning isn't always pretty, guys.
We gotta...
It's all about...
We gotta make it, like, you know, more exciting.
Because if you play perfectly, then it won't be as exciting
to watch, guys.
Not like people watch, like, the best players in the world
or anything.
people like watching like people who are good at the game
they just they like people they like to watch people who are
adequate you know you know i'm like i'm like the tim tim
tatman of vtubers i'm the tim the tatman of vtubers guys
there you go that's me
okay there i got the rocket i don't know why my frame i
might i actually look he do want to go into dual dual pcs
going in backwards three two one okay whoa yep he dropped
okay he definitely was in the backline oh my god he
definitely was in the backline though you said he was gonna
go That was crazy.
That was a crazy hook.
I think we need our triple DPS.
I don't know why we went triple support.
Like, their triple support was not working.
Oh, I guess for the Spider-Man?
Oh, no.
That's awkward.
It's okay.
support us we like guys it's okay we triple killed them
that's the strat I do not have all yet which is bad
there you go I'm alive all right someone's gonna get eaten
and he's not gonna be me
Oh, there's the second up There it is That spider-man is up
Okay, there we go
There we go I need a reload rocket
There we go I Oh my god, please like that was a good ass
freeze That freeze was sick How many FPS I'm looking I like
playing with 200 I think I just played I played Rival's off
stream way too much So I'm used to looking at like 200
frames Because now it's like bouncing It's not fully 200 so
it's like I'm like
So it's like bothering me.
Oh, I thought he was going to go left.
I miscounted.
Or I misjudged.
Wait, that guy's low.
Oh, that guy's dead.
Oh.
Where is he?
He has no light up.
That guy's going to jump in.
Oh, shit.
Rock it off guy right now.
Oh.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, fuck it.
Oh, it's okay.
There's a hot guy in the pool tonight.
I know.
Oh, God.
Hey, guys.
We gotta stop.
Oh, nice.
They see nine.
Run and double.
It's even funnier the second time when we double support.
I bet.
Guys, it's just...
It's even funnier.
here there we go it was planned exactly it's just even
funnier when it happens again
easy yeah double support alt versus c9 will win plus 17 i
thought this was an eternity lobby Was it not?
Come on, I didn't do too bad.
Alright, I gotta check.
And then it goes downhill here.
I didn't see the average.
Yeah, what the fuck?
How do I get a fucking plus 17?
I didn't do too bad there.
I had some sick ass freezes.
Come on.
Those freezes were fucking sick.
I didn't even miss it.
Okay.
All right.
I'm not jinxing it.
I said it all goes downhill here.
Guys.
You know what?
I should be able to grab water.
I'll be right back.
Don't worry.
I need more water.
I finished my water.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Now, who is going to vanish from this match?
Let me do that real.
I did it.
all right we have good timing we're just doing our bad
phases you don't have a support player except for me but
that's okay
that's all right we're
gaming as long as we're gaming guys everything is fine it's
true it's not about winning it's about the memories we we
make That is true.
Hashtag goals.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
But I'm bum bum.
Alright.
I shall play.
I deserve to play Rocket.
I after in between Luna games I get to play Rocket.
If I get, if I have to play Luna I get to play Rocket.
it but sometimes we take stuff other people are garbage
unicorn they give a little twitch prime thank you thank you
left voice chat why did that godly voice chat because we're
on triple tank oh no we're on triple tank guys oh never mind
oh never mind oh let's go solo support time Is Rocket Meta?
He is.
Because we banned everything.
Technically it is because everything got bad.
I get to chill.
Oh, there's Hulk.
Here he comes.
Oh, there's Thor.
They won't know I'm here.
How would he know?
I'm in the smoke.
They're walling if he knows.
Oh my god.
It'll be fine, right?
He was not fine.
And it's okay.
He gets west.
Or bad.
Look, see?
He still don't know.
Look at that.
They're like, where is this?
Oh my god.
I'm climbing.
You're on your own.
If the wolf's on me, burn him.
He was like, he should run in.
I was like, no, bro.
I'm staying here.
I'm staying down there.
Oh, this sucks.
We don't have...
Oh, wait.
I could technically play cloak.
Because, um, you don't have mag.
But why play...
Oh, yeah.
I should play cloak because they have Phoenix now.
There's no...
You know what?
They're not going to see this.
Oh, he got stunned.
Nope.
A little overkill, but that's cool.
Wait, I'll grab this so they don't see...
Yeah!
I'll let...
I'll let her out first.
Alright.
There's no way they know it's here.
They might see the floating armor.
Wait.
You can out first.
I'm about to hit my wall.
Oh.
Everything is fine.
You'll be fine, right?
Okay.
Yeah, I was gonna say!
You'll be fine, right?
It's fine over there.
Oh, I fucked up the wall.
I wasn't gonna do that.
Oh my god.
I mean, I'm fine with that.
Okay.
but I don't know what okay That's fine wait, we're still
okay.
It's okay one Our Luna comes back.
See our Luna comes back.
Oh my god catch my balls Catch it There we go.
See you got it Doki help.
I'm stuck in GM.
I'm sorry.
It's terminal I'm sorry
see look how chill playing rock it is after you know season
zero season one i'm like i want to earn my rate via skill
and now in season six season 5.5 i'm like it's fine as long
as i win i win i'm like look all as long as i win i'm fine
Least amount of effort to gain the Eno.
A win's a win.
Exactly.
It's all about the min-max.
Watch this.
I'm here.
It'll be fine.
Yeah, see?
Catch my balls!
A win's a win.
We're not here to make it harder for ourselves.
It's all about what is the easiest way to grab snatch
victory.
Don't save that.
I personally think...
GM is low.
If you're especially like this late, but also...
But also, we are not the same.
I'll be brutally honest.
Whoa!
Damn!
I won't lie to you!
I...
I'm not here to sugarcoat it.
This is motivation for you.
All right, damn.
Yeah, we have...
Yeah, I don't have a life.
Look, look, I'm not saying that as if...
No, I don't have a life, guys.
I don't...
You guys...
You guys have more of a life than me.
When I'm sad, I play Marvel Rivals.
When I'm happy, I play Marvel Rivals.
When I'm here...
I'm disassociating.
I play Marvel Rivals.
We are not the same.
That's sad.
It's not...
Exactly.
That doesn't sound like a...
You don't want to be like me.
So embrace the GM life.
Embrace it.
That means you have a life.
Oh, so it's terminal.
It's good!
When you play Marble Rivals.
I don't even have to- I can look at chat while I play Marble
Rivals.
Please shoot the squid.
You can be saved.
Thank you for the super- I think even tier 1 something.
You did something eco bird.
going on yeah i was gonna say that's a lot
we but we can fix it i'm sorry it's terminal it is
unfortunately terminal
it is unfortunately terminal you know what there you go I
was like, I'm like, this.
Dot bomb!
Dot bomb from above!
My good deed for the day.
Yeah.
She's too far, God.
Is this what you tell a child?
If you were to say, I want to be just like you.
I'm like, you don't want to be just like me.
You don't.
You don't want this.
Not like you.
Don't be like your hero.
Come back to me.
Listen, my child.
It's not too late for you.
We can still save you.
That is.
But yes.
really do you want to get better well obviously i don't know
how to do support for rank up if you do want to fucking rank
up as support play gambit that's it's you gotta learn oh but
then gambit will be meta for next season so play gambit if
it's not bad if it is then good luck or in fine i guess no
dps duo is better than tank duo i think dps does make it
more of an impact.
A DPS player that knows how to play tank.
Just, okay, here are the meta characters.
If you're a GM.
Invis, Gambit, Rocket, and Loki.
Everything else is like, if everything else is bad, you play
Luna, but Luna's still pretty dog shit.
Oh, Joki of the hot Elo.
How do I get to your Elo?
play gambit
having a DPS deal also means you're not getting a spotty OTP
oh it absolutely means you're gonna get a spotty OTP but it
it just means that it doesn't do anything you can never
avoid spotty OTPs
can I get out of Elohella by Hardmane Magneto no only
because only because there's so many every tank knows how to
play mag and it doesn't really matter it doesn't I think by
season 6 because mag has been meta for 6 seasons every tank
player has now learned how to play mag whether they like to
or not because if they don't play mag you lose because mag
just mag just counters every fucking support all and every
other dps so even if you're even your tank even if your tank
otp is not mag you eventually have to play mag if you're a
tank player that pool will be out in two days oh less than
two days a day in it's like 24 hours right yeah a day in
five hours so 29 hours he is unfortunately the best tank
right now i mean Like, the best way is to...
Oh, hey.
Everyone's just sitting.
It's just have good positioning.
He's got to have really good positioning, too.
Why do they love Mag and hate Strange?
Because Strange isn't meta anymore.
That's really it.
He's not meta.
Oh, it does.
Because Strange had it too good for too long.
But they don't want to target Mag.
Because then people will think they're racist towards
mutants.
Because he is literally...
the immunity representative.
They're just your cowards.
True!
Damn, dude.
They'll be like, oh, so you hate mutants, huh?
And you're like, oh, no, we won't.
That's why I went to the nerf bag!
That's one way.
But Emma, though.
Emma is one of the strongest fucking tanks out there.
They buff all the mutants.
This is not a conspiracy.
I'm like a conspiracy theorist.
Guys, I swear to God.
They're buffing all the mutants.
They're trying to take over the world.
What do you mean?
I swear.
Best support.
Oh, Gambit and Luna.
Best DPS.
I don't know.
DPS is like a ballpark.
DPS is like everything, to be fair.
Scylok is always like...
Scylok!
and Phoenix.
Best tank?
Mag and Emma.
Oh.
This is no longer a conspiracy.
Why are the non-mutants always getting nerfed?
But then the mutants, all the mutants are getting buffed.
This is Magneto's America.
Wait, she has a point.
It's a fact.
Whoa!
That's crazy!
That right, brother!
That right, brother.
Makes you think, doesn't it?
Anyway.
The water's making...
The water's making the frogs mutants!
That's crazy.
And then the non-munits are always getting nerfed.
What is this?
I'm J.
Jonas.
And there's like a guy on the cart.
There's like two guys on the two burly men on the cart.
aren't right now.
There we go.
How did we win that?
I guess because I didn't die?
Okay, I just assumed because I didn't die.
That's crazy.
JJ.
I'm the...
I'm anti-JJ.
It's like anti-venom.
He fights for the mutants and I fight for the...
I...
I don't.
Relay deployed.
It ain't cheap.
You're halfway there.
Fuck it.
Surely they kill somebody down there.
Nice.
Yeah.
I don't want pictures of Spider-Man.
The anti-JJ.
I apologize.
I appreciate that, G.
Okay.
Yeah, do not send me pictures of Spider-Man.
Yeah, what pictures of Rocket?
Literally, I'm getting that every fucking day.
She's Phoenix, guys.
Okay, that's in the open.
We don't want that.
Is this heading anywhere?
Oh, that's okay.
I do have res.
Where did he go?
Oh, he fucked up.
What is going on?
Like, what is going on?
What the fuck?
At least I can push guard now.
I want pictures of venom.
That's true.
Give me pictures of venom.
Is this...
Unfortunately, this is not quickly.
Hmm.
Isn't it crazy that this is actually a regular game that I'm
playing right now?
Oh shit, is that Venom on our cart?
That's fine.
He's fine.
He might not be... He's fine still.
Okay, they're on triple support now.
From one... We have one support.
offer.
I give you one support.
They need to triple support.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
And so there is a cloak right.
Okay, so we technically we missed question mark.
Oh.
Where did I put my res?
I think it's working.
There you go.
Alright, here you go.
That's wild.
Who would win one support or three supports or three DPS?
This is wild.
I think our DPS players are just better.
Like, I think...
Boxy, please.
I am doing my best to keep you alive right now.
i don't think he sees my res which is good it's okay it's
okay moxie if you die we still have a res oh that is very
unfortunate it's okay it's it's okay our
hello where did he go hello i'm i mean i'm i'm What do you
want from me?
What do you...
I'm one guy.
Like, all I do is just right click.
That's all I can do.
You can't blame me for anything.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
Good luck, Moxie.
Okay.
Oh, that is unfortunate.
That is also unfortunate.
It's okay, he comes back.
He can, okay, he can not come back from this.
It's okay.
I do have, oh, oh, oh, oh, Ultron?
Ultron, we have decided to run another.
All right.
Goodbye
Where is he?
Wait, he's he's he didn't do it All right, here we go Click
hard There you go.
Is that hard enough?
Yeah
It is a little weird that we oh my god.
They're running true.
I don't I think they just don't have DPS players I think the
enemy team just have zero DPS players.
I think...
That's crazy.
Okay.
I legitimately think that...
I think that this team just have zero.
I think we're at three takes, three supports.
I think we took all the DPS players.
Yeah, we stole all of them.
That's insane.
Round two.
I don't know how we like...
I have no idea how that happened.
We snuffed it all up.
Our team literally had all the DPS base.
Let's go!
But anyway, as I was saying about my mutant propaganda, like
anti-propaganda, Yeah, anti-mutant propaganda every
character that's been a mutant has been either buffed or Not
touched yet every non-mutant character has been nerfed to a
Bolivian Coincidence I think not
That's no coincidence in my book Well, I think the Jeff is
now a DPS, though.
I'm just trying to heal our Thor.
No, she's dead.
She's dead.
Guys, it's just me.
Guys, you are...
You are unfortunately taking a lot of damage.
They don't know.
Oh my god, this doesn't...
Oh no.
It's okay.
I flew up.
It's awkward.
Oh my god, that's so awkward.
No!
She ran away!
The Luna ran away!
You ain't got rid of me yet.
Mom, if...
Okay, I did not expect it to fucking flyer.
My throw was just...
I just didn't know my strength.
Okay, guys.
My bad.
I didn't know my strength, guys.
I just didn't know I was that strong.
Guys, I just didn't know.
I didn't like mutants.
Bro, it's not my fault.
Everyone dies so fast.
Everyone fucking dies so fast.
How is that?
I like literally am trying to keep you alive right now.
Oh my god, I'm trying to.
I'm trying to heal everyone.
Everybody right now Okay
I have to fucking balance in between two people you cannot
blame me for this I'm literally trying to fucking heal
between two fucking people two groups Okay, there you go
there should be five
there you go we should have good luck everyone there we go
everyone is okay
oh my god who was he trying to get who was he trying to get
i don't know
is it our luna oh it was our luna oh my And he got the Res
Beacon, too.
At the last moment.
That's so unlucky.
Oh, no.
Oh, my.
I almost got out.
I might actually have to go Luna.
No, it's not.
No, these guys are all just...
Okay, good luck, I'll try.
Good luck.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're still okay.
We're on Spider-Man.
We're playing Mr. Hero.
right now we didn't even get the point back but it's okay I
got it back oh shit okay that was too much damage it's okay
behold God of thunder oh it's mossy on spider-man now say we
have mantis up oh my Oh my god.
Please.
Get me in it.
Oh my god.
I'm in it.
I'm in it now.
I am.
I made it.
I have made it.
Oh shit.
Guys, guys, guys, I'm on point.
I'm on point.
I got on point for us.
Bro.
the fuck did he ult me guys i think you know what would
that's very unfortunate that was very unfortunate oh my god
are you kidding me
Oh my god.
What the fuck was this game?
Three point.
Holy shit.
They wanted me dead.
I was so scared.
just a little guy just a little fucking guy so thank you for
the little twitch for i think thank you yay eternity yay
they said fuck you in particular yippee
oh my god not getting top 500 bro top 500 is like eternity
200 right now that shit is far that shit is too far we just
playing the plan i was not expecting us to climb that much
what a game to get eternity one quick grind in and out
that's what we all say and then you know what happens it's
not one game it's not one quick grind see guys ever since i
told you guys to start believing we win now with that
attitude dude thank you for the gifted tier one sub
yeah think about yeah think about the leaderboard though bro
that's crazy they literally had three supports back to my
people in and in for eternity
finally some diversity
finally they finally recruited more dancers in the club
There we go.
That's what I'm talking about.
You gotta have some more, like, diversity.
My variety, you know?
My variety to your dancers.
Club Doki is popping right now.
I know, I'm a businesswoman.
There we go.
We are enjoying our time.
Look, we gotta relax.
After the hard game we had, we have to relax now, you know?
Oh, those Spider-Man's got...
We gotta...
We gotta relax now.
Oh, you're right.
Give me a sec.
Where is...
I think...
I'm pretty sure I have it equipped.
No!
What's the point?
This is why we play Rivals.
oh shit this is a game game now now we gaming what
you do you think you want to be today
all right
whoa the lunar player in this day and age who am I gonna
banish from this match uh oh it's game game time all right
we we stop when we lose a game which could potentially be
this game.
It could potentially be this one.
But we had a good run.
We had a really good run, guys.
You have to admit.
When we lose a two game.
Yeah, but then you're going to start a cycle.
It'll be like, oh, but what if we lose three games?
Oh, you won a game.
You can't stop on a...
You can't stop on a win.
A win streak is here.
I know your games.
Erica, what were you saying to me last game?
What?
Wait, what?
What was worse?
What did they say?
You need a top-notch team to win this one.
Oh, I must have missed the...
Oh, my gun...
Cool.
What?
Okay, I get it now.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
I get it.
It took me a while.
He's like, oh.
Yeah, you were saying like crazy words in the old chat.
Oh, like I was asking like if my gun tasted good.
before you attack you know get ready oh well how did they
yeah very i like did it taste bad like um i have covet so i
can't really taste anything right now
oh damn solid response good response good response two one
Most normal rival.
I'm not ashamed.
Oh.
It's okay, I got you, girl.
We gotta protect the gaunt.
We gotta help her.
Oh my god, I tried to fucking heal.
Holy shit, that's a fast up.
Protect what?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's so low.
That was such a good pull too.
Okay.
Oh.
Hello.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh.
Well.
Oh, we'll be fine, right?
He's gonna...
Oh my
god, that's scared of shit.
He doesn't know where I am.
He's like, surely, surely she's right here.
She jumped, she has to be in the air.
right now surely that's crazy surely she's flying right oh
he fucking don't know where oh my god I told this is why I
play rocket this is too much are you serious okay it's okay
Oh, oh, we don't have support Come on, keep backing up There
you go I'm here too much thinking you saw how easy it was
how easy it was when we were on oh nice, okay When we were
on rocket no think just shoot.
Jeez, please Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa Whoa Whoa, whoa Oh
Oh All right, it's fine.
Amun...
We have been getting a lot of...
I will say, we've been getting a lot of...
Thor players.
And Moon Knight players, too.
A lot of Moon Knight and Thor players in general.
I'm going to let our Luna build up.
Never mind, I gotta save him.
Oh,
that's unfortunate.
That is very unfortunate.
Oh fuck, I thought he was gonna up.
That's unlucky.
Wait, okay, I'll let Luna go first.
All right, you can go first.
Yeah, Luna go first.
Yeah, I thought she was ulting first.
Because she ulted first last time.
So, but, you know, pattern-wise, pattern-wise, it would stay
the same.
There you go.
You know, you won't...
You need a rule of...
Alright.
That...
Oh, that pull was sick!
Oh, I am very sorry.
Get pulled.
I'll get pulled for the sake of it just for fun Okay, I do
What?
Oh my god
Oh, that's so unlucky that is so that was bullshit That was
bullshit I did not think I didn't think I would die from
that.
I should have fucking ulted earlier.
That was my bad.
Please.
I'm protecting you.
Like a good support.
Oh my god.
I will think it might be easier if I'm dead here.
Yeah.
I think it might be.
be easier if we run in this Loki.
I think this person is a Lula one trick though.
Because Loki is just too strong.
She might be ace, but Loki is just way too good.
It just the tempo wise is better for our team.
Alright here.
What's going?
Oh.
Oh my god, I just got y'all.
The current score is 1, 2, 0.
I literally just got it too.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
I think Loki's just a better pick overall.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Would it be nice to get a better DPS than Moon Knight?
He is doing a lot though.
He's getting alt like fucking crazy.
I just think like momentum wise it'd be easier with loki
only because his in barn and like we can have double
invisible i don't think double i don't think luno is like as
strong invisible is just too good
i knew guys i told you i told you guys this way it needed to
end somewhere Guan Guan gave me an Audi.
He gave me an Audi.
Because I was like, I'll play until I lose.
And he was like, this is it.
Right here.
You deserve it.
An Audi.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He actually dodged it the moment.
Oh, I forgot to ref- I forgot to pull my fucking shield
back, though.
That's not good.
Drop me.
Oh, but he's so low!
Oh, God.
Oh, yeah.
No!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, here.
I'm gonna try.
Okay.
I don't know what...
happen to my Luna, though.
I literally just got it.
I literally just got my...
That sucks.
I don't know what happened to my Luna, though.
I had to push up.
I mean...
I should kill him.
Yeah, I didn't see it.
I mean, I can ult this.
Oh, we have a...
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
But never mind.
Let's not go.
I'm helping.
I'm fucking.
Let's go.
Our guy was gonna die, but I didn't do it.
I had to save his life.
I had to start something.
I had to start a war.
I hear something, though.
I hear some clicky clackies.
Oh my god, that's unfortunate.
Oh, that is very unfortunate.
Oh my Guys, guys, okay, I guess I'll stay here.
All right, that's fine.
Oh, never mind.
We didn't touch four.
One, two, two.
Oh, my God, Mochi, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Okay, look.
Luna.
Oh, my God.
Wait, the Luna's B.M.
Oh.
At least the 1411 guy got blamed Yeah, yeah Yeah,
Moxie didn't get blamed Moxie didn't get blamed And he's
like, that's fine I'm fine with that That's crazy That's
crazy that Moxie gets away for free Never blame the streamer
guys It's damn Okay, we'll do one more.
Okay, wait.
Am I, like, 16 as in, like, I get leeway, or what?
Where is this?
I can't see.
Do I get negative?
Guys, I don't want to lose eternity.
Do I get?
Wait, do I get one more loss, or what is it?
Oh, I don't.
I don't.
Guys, I either lose eternity.
I'm calling it.
I lose eternity.
Yo, Moxie, I'm calling it.
I told my stream, I end at a loss.
We had a good...
We had a good win streak going.
A coward?
Guys, I'm keeping my eternity.
Oh, wait.
I think Moxie...
I think Moxie left.
Hi.
Yeah.
I fucking went BRB?
have my stream on on my phone i rushed immediately back ggs
man ggs we had we we won a lot we won a lot yeah we those
are solid street yeah i like i like the how that guy did not
he's like bro fuck our tank bro like yeah like yeah exactly
it wasn't you and i didn't get blamed too yeah i over our
two two support olds i died in my support on choice but not
my fault as long as we're not blamed we're good yeah yeah
it's never the streamers fault you know that's why we stream
exactly yeah yeah ggs though ggs man are you still going oh
yeah i might go a little bit i'll send you the raid over to
you man i see you we run back we gotta run back later later
later bye all right oh shit oh what the fuck he broke my
game he left at the same time yeah that was fun though never
planned Yeah, like, I'm glad the other Erica did not blame
me either because we did fuck up to support old suit But he
was like fucker tank 14 11 and I'm like not me
Not me or moxie not us Anyway, I had a great stream.
I had a really fun time playing as always I hope you guys
had a fun time watching guys.
I decided to tap out here.
I wanted to keep I wanted to keep that So that's right.
I'm a coward, but I'm a smart cat.
I'm a coward, but look who's still eternity, though.
That's like, right?
That's me.
Look who's still eternity.
Look, look, wait, wait.
Actually, it should shake his ass.
All right.
Wait, let me.
We gotta show our love right here.
And then give me a sec.
Bam.
Look who's still eternity.
All right, guys.
Thank you all for watching.
Huge shout out again to Cowardly Bird.
Thank you for the gifted subs to Cowardly Bird.
Thank you.
Thank you all for the raids, the subs, the follows, the
bitties.
Thank you, everyone.
I hope you guys have fun time.
Huge shout out again to your rivals for sponsoring me for
today's stream.
great time a great time with my team um um and if you guys
want to check me out through other platforms please follow
me on youtube i do stream this i as my main platform um and
i do my most of my streams there so check me out there on
youtube if you guys want to know whenever i stream on twitch
please feel free to follow me on twitter uh exclamation
point socials check me out there i usually tweet out
whenever i do twitch streams because uh this is like my
second uh my second stream uh platform um and i usually do
gorilla streams or sponsors over here um what else what else
you want to support me via other means check out my merch
exclamation point merch it does help out a lot and make sure
to click the links pinned in the chat in the panel to
support the sponsor and the stream and this channel um
anyway guys i'm gonna head off now as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you still free me head to bed cause you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys